la séance est ouverte
bonjour à tous l'ordre du jour appelle
la discussion après engagement de la
procédure accélérée du projet de loi
adopté par le Sénat relatif à
l'industrie verte et nous commençons en
écoutant le ministre de l'Économie des
Finances de la souveraineté industrielle
et numérique Monsieur Bruno Le Maire à
qui je cède la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame Monsieur
est rapporteur monsieur le ministre cher
Roland Lescure mesdames et messieurs les
députés nous sommes très heureux avec
Roland Lescure de vous présenter
aujourd'hui ce projet de loi pour une
industrie verte
le 4 septembre 1958 place de la
République le Général de Gaulle
affirmait la nécessité de rénover
l'industrie nous pousse à être dynamique
et expéditif
voilà exactement ce que nous vous
proposons avec ce projet de loi
industrie verte être dynamique et
expéditif pour réindustrialiser la
France et décarbonée sans délai notre
industrie nationale
en 1958 le choix économique se posait en
des termes simples
reconstruire ou périr
la France a fait le choix à l'époque de
la reconstruction elle a bâti elle a
innové elle a électrifié elle a créé une
filière de centrale nucléaire et elle a
gagné la bataille économique
en 2023 je le reconnais bien volontiers
le choix se pose dans des termes plus
complexes
reconstruire notre industrie sans périr
car au défi de leur industrialisation
défi économiques vitales
s'ajoutent le défi de la décarbonation
de notre économie qui est un défi vital
tout court
pour répondre à ce défi il y a deux
options possibles dont nous allons
débattre tout au long de nos échanges
la décroissance de la production
ou la décarbonation de la croissance
notre choix avec la majorité est fait
nous voulons résolument faire le choix
de la décarbonation de la croissance et
nous refusons tout aussi résolument le
choix de la décroissance qui conduirait
à la pauvrissement des Français et à la
pauvrissement notre nation le choix la
décarbonation de la croissance il
conjugue la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et l'innovation
le climat et la prospérité la réduction
des émissions et l'industrie pourquoi
est-ce que nous faisons ce choix de la
décarbonation de notre croissance nous
le faisons pour trois raisons
la première c'est tout simplement
l'avenir de notre nation
nous voulons que la nation française
reste une nation de production qui
conserve et développe une production
manufacturière à haute valeur ajoutée
dans les décennies qui viennent
inutile de nous attarder trop longtemps
sur le suicide économique de la
désindustrialisation
ce suicide économique qui a été commis
au cours des quatre dernières décennies
qui est le produit d'une nation qui
renonce à elle-même d'une nation qui se
trahit d'une donation qui a détruit 2
millions d'emplois industriels fermés
600 usines et bafoué sa culture ouvrière
triste bilan d'une triste politique ou
plutôt d'une absence de politique je
préfère avec les députés de la majorité
insister sur le succès de notre
réindustrialisation que nous avons
engagé avec le président de la
République depuis 2017 en nous
affranchissant d'un certain nombre de
tabous comme la fiscalité du capital
nous avons abaissé la fiscalité du
capital tout simplement parce qu'il n'y
a pas d'industrie son capital et qu'il
n'y a pas de développement industriel
sans fiscalité favorable pour le capital
nous avons depuis 2017 et dans les deux
dernières années créées près de 100 000
emplois industriels ouverts 300 usines
développées des investissements
industriels massifs à Crolles à
Dunkerque à Douvrin partout ailleurs sur
le territoire c'est le résultat de votre
politique mesdames et messieurs les
députés de la majorité et vous pouvez en
être fiers
[Applaudissements]
nous le faisons pour une deuxième raison
qui est l'emploi
nous voulons que la France crée des
emplois qualifiés et des emplois bien
rémunérés c'est-à-dire des emplois
industriels
l'industrie en France doit retrouver ses
lettres de noblesse et l'ouvrier ces
titres de gloire dans l'électricité dans
la chimie dans l'automobile dans
l'aéronautique dans le luxe ou dans le
médicament ouvrier et ingénieur doivent
occuper désormais une place centrale
dans notre économie une place qu'ils ont
toujours occupé et qui n'auraient déjà
jamais dû perdre au cours des quatre
dernières décennies
nous le faisons pour une troisième
raison
la troisième raison pour laquelle nous
voulons engager la décarbonation entre
l'économie c'est tout simplement pour le
climat
et je voudrais combattre ici un
raisonnement rapide et comme beaucoup de
raisonnement rapide un raisonnement faux
produire moins en France ce serait
pollué moins ce serait donc préservé la
planète c'est l'exacte contraire car la
frange le rappelle émet de 2 à 5 fois
moins de CO2 par unité produite sur
notre territoire que par ses grands
partenaires économiques là où nous
émettons 100 tonnes de CO2 par milliard
de PIB produits
c'est 229 aux États-Unis et ses 500 en
Chine
à chaque fois que nous délocalisons nous
réimportons des produits qui sont
lourdement carbonés à chaque fois que
nous produisons en France nous
décarbonnons notre économie et nous
décarbonons la planète c'est bien la
raison principale pour laquelle il faut
accélérer le développement de
l'industrie verte sur notre territoire
comme nous vous le proposons produire
plus en France ces produire mieux et
c'est exactement ce que vous propose ce
projet de loi
alors comment allons-nous faire
il y a dans cette loi sur l'industrie
verte deux objets principaux
le premier c'est de décarboner
l'industrie existante
car on ne construira pas l'industrie et
de demain sur les ruines de l'industrie
d'hier c'est tout le contraire les
grands sites industriels de fosses de
Dunkerque de Crolles et d'ailleurs ont
besoin de se décarboner et d'être
accompagné dans leur décarbonation il
n'est pas question de les laisser tomber
il est question au contraire de les
accompagner et de les soutenir dans leur
décarbonation le deuxième objectif c'est
d'investir dans des technologies clés 5
technologies clés choisies mesurer
l'hydrogène vert les pompes à chaleur
les batteries électriques l'éolien et
les panneaux photovoltaïques toutes les
technologies vertes d'aujourd'hui et de
demain qui nous permettront d'être aux
avant-postes de l'industrie du 21e
siècle
quels instruments est-ce que nous allons
vous proposer dans ce projet de loi
industrie verte je laisserai à Roland
Lescure le choix de présenter les
détails du projet de loi et je voudrais
juste pour terminer insister sur trois
principes nouveaux et fondamentaux qui
brise certains tabous qui brillent
certaines habitudes ou qui reviennent
sur une certaine paresse politique
premier principe
l'impôt n'est pas la solution et pour
financer la décarbonation et
l'investissement industriel ce n'est
certainement pas en augmentant les
impôts qu'on ne réussirons à accélérer
la décarbonation de notre économie au
contraire pour financer la transition
écologique il faut inventer de nouveaux
modes de financement qui passent par les
normes par les signals prix et par les
pagnes
la norme tripleux qui vous est proposée
dans ce projet de loi permettra
d'inciter justement à la décarbonation
des entreprises quant à l'épargne le
produit d’épargne vert que nous vous
proposons le Plan d'Épargne à venir
climat nous permettra précisément de
lever 5 milliards d'euros pour financer
la transition climatique et l'industrie
verte je rappelle qu'il y a en France
5800 milliards d'euros d'épargne
financière des ménages français il me
semble qu'une petite partie d'entre
elles pourraient être redistribuée à bon
escient vers la décarbonation de notre
économie sans qu'il soit besoin de créer
un ISF vers je ne sais trop quel impôt
ou je ne sais trop quel prélèvement
supplémentaire dans un pays qui a déjà
le record du monde des prélèvements
obligatoires de tous les pays développés
deuxième principe la vitesse est clé on
ne peut pas dire qu'il y a urgence
climatique d'un côté et ralentir de
l'autre la réalisation de projets qui
permettent de décarboner notre industrie
et d'accélérer la transition climatique
nous vous proposerons donc d'accélérer
les procédures
le troisième principe auquel je tiens
beaucoup c'est celui de la préférence
européenne et de la préférence accordée
au contenu européen là aussi les choses
sont simples plus il y a de contenu
européens dans un produit industriel
moins il y a de CO2 il me semble donc
que les bonus sur les véhicules
électriques et que même tous les
avantages fiscaux devraient d'abord être
réservés à des produits à Contenus
européens c'est-à-dire des produits à
Contenus décarbonés et je souhaite que
cette évidence nationale devienne demain
une évidence européenne voilà les grands
éléments de ce projet de loi industrie
verte nous allons examiner aujourd'hui
je me réjouis que vous soyez venu
nombreux cet après-midi je ne doute pas
que vous serez encore plus nombreux dans
les heures qui viennent l'industrie
française le mérite la transition
climatique encore plus merci à tous
merci
merci monsieur le ministre vous
succèdent le ministre délégué chargé de
l'Industrie Monsieur Roland Lescure
ça va
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Économie des Finances de
la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique cher Bruno monsieur le
Président cher Bruno décidément il faut
s'appeler Bruno pour être président
aujourd'hui bonjour à tous les deux
monsieur le rapporteur général
ou Sébastien
et boire de la mental aujourd'hui je
vois donc
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames messieurs les députés
ces deux derniers mois
le président de la République a inauguré
le sixième salon tchuss France avec 28
annonces 13 milliards d'euros
d'investissement 8000 emplois à la clé
la première ministre a présidé le
Conseil national de l'industrie il y a
une quinzaine de jours avec la
présentation j'ai eu l'honneur de la
faire de la feuille de la feuille de
route de décarbonation des 56 les plus
émetteurs de France qui a au sol
représente 60% des émissions de gaz
effet de serre de l'industrie française
le ministre d'économie a des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle
numérique a inauguré à Douvrin dans le
Pas-de-Calais une gigafactory qui va
fournir plus de 25% des batteries
françaises pour les véhicules
électriques le président de la
République a annoncé le rapatriement de
25 médicaments essentiels qui seront
produits en France vivatech est
désormais le premier salon numérique au
monde devant le CES de Las Vegas au
Bourget le premier Salon International
de l'Aéronautique et de l'Espace s'est
tenu en 4 ans mettant clairement la
France et l'Europe sur la carte mondiale
de la décarbonation de l'industrie
aéronautique
une variable clé vous le savez la France
exporte aujourd'hui 50% des avions dans
le monde si la France décarbonne son
industrie aéronautique ce seront 50%
madame Rousseau des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre des avions mondiaux qui
auront disparu grâce à la France nous
avons inauguré le Vercors Innovation
Center en Isère nous avons annoncé 237
l'oréante 2023 lors du concours
d'innovation de France 2030 montrant que
les startups ne sont plus des logiciels
construits dans un garage par deux
entrepreneurs visionnaires mais bien
l'avenir de l'industrie française nous
avons inauguré avec le ministre et avec
la présidente de la région
Occitanie une nouvelle chaîne de
production d'Airbus bref en deux mois
beaucoup beaucoup c'est fait pour
montrer que l'industrie française est de
retour évidemment ces deux moines sont
pas arrivés par hasard ils sont le fruit
ils sont le résultat des travaux engagés
le ministre l'a dit depuis 6 ans par
cette majorité pour laquelle nous devons
accélérer le travail
et moi ce qui m'a frappé sur tous ces
projets et d'autres que je vais
mentionner rapidement c'est que quand on
est sur le terrain l'Union nationale
autour de l'industrie l'Union nationale
autour de la décarbonation de
l'industrie elle est possible
aujourd'hui nous retrouvons à chaque
fois ça fait un an que je suis ministre
de l'Industrie sans déplacement sur le
terrain nous retrouvons des élus de tout
bord qui sont d'accord sur très peu de
choses sur ce que doit nous amener la
politique nationale la politique
économique
la politique d'immigration la politique
sociale la politique sociétale mais sur
l'industrie je suis convaincu parce que
je le vois tous les jours sur le terrain
que nous sommes prêts de l'Union
nationale nous sommes prêts à aligner
les écosystèmes pour construire les
industries pour construire à des
carbonation de demain pour accompagner
les territoires en difficulté pour
sauver de leur point industriel
évidemment pour créer la prospérité
d'aujourd'hui et de demain quelques
exemples
déplacement wave le 28 mai cher au
député le coq qui était il s'en souvient
le député vulfranc n'était pas très loin
madame la rapporteur madame la députée
poussié vinzak était là également avec
sa collègue madame Carrel une
vice-présidente de la Région Virginie
carololutro Alban Bruno mère communiste
non vous n'étiez pas là Monsieur jumelle
c'était pas pour l'éolien c'était pour
les engrais mais votre absence m'a déçu
mais vous m'aviez vous-même expliqué que
vous aviez d'autres engagements Edouard
Philippe mer du Havre et président de
l'agglomération vous étiez tous là
vous étiez tout cela pour annoncer ma
mise en place au Havre et dans sa région
d'une zone industrielle bas carbone d'un
plan de souveraineté et de décarbonation
de l'industrie de l'engrais du
développement de la capture carbone bref
de la décarbonation de l'industrie de 4
des 50 principaux sites l'Union
nationale mesdames et messieurs les
députés elle est possible et grâce à ce
projet de loi le projet de décarbonation
de la zone du Havre elle sera simplifiée
par les procédures d'installation CF
l'article 2 elle sera aussi simplifiée
par la mutualisation et la concertation
préalable sur une zone géographique
donnée c'est dans l'article 3
en Aveyron aujourd'hui on a un grand
industriel européen allemand Bosch pour
ne pas le citer qui annonce des
difficultés dans la diversification
engagée avec les syndicats qui ont signé
un accord avec eux il y a deux ans pour
préserver ce site industriel qui est
évidemment cher à tous les élus de
l'Aveyron Monsieur Laurent Alexandre ici
présent les députés Rousset et Mazar le
président du département à l'audiant
Arnaud Viala pardon du groupe la
République 1 42ga la Présidente nous
sommes tous rassemblés pour que cette
industrie qui aujourd'hui fait face au
défi majeur de la transition du moteur
thermique vers le moteur électrique
puisse l'assurer en préservant l'emploi
et là évidemment aussi ce projet de loi
il jouera un rôle extrêmement important
tout ça pour vous dire quoi mesdames et
messieurs les députés pour vous dire que
je suis convaincu qu'autour de ce projet
de loi ici en hémicycle nous devons
faire ce que nous sommes tous capables
de faire ensemble sur le terrain libérez
notre ustrie libérer les procédures
libérer du foncier libéré du financement
mais oui tout en préservant la planète
tout en même donnant les conditions de
la TEC carbonation de l'industrie de
manière à ce que la France soit la
première économie des carbonée du monde
je vais pas passer toutes les mesures en
[Musique]
voyant on va aller vite allez je vais
les passer rapidement mais permettez-moi
quand même de vous rappeler quelques
mesures essentielles mettre à
disposition dans l'industrie 56
intégralement des pollués représentant
2000 hectares rehausser la créance
environnementale au rang de créances
privilégiée
divisé par deux les délais d'ouverture
ou d'agrandissement d'une usine en
France de 17 mois réels à neuf mois
effectif
et évidemment en aucun cas on
affaiblissant ni les études d'impact ni
les consultations publiques vous le
savez nous les renforçons nous
souhaitons aussi mettre en place des
projets d'intérêt national sans
évidemment en aucun cas affaiblir la
capacité des élus locaux à se prononcer
sur leur pertinence c'est l'article 9
nous souhaitons libérer le financement
dans une période contrainte sur le plan
budgétaire le ministre Bruno Le Maire
l'a dit 6000 milliards ou presque
d'euros aujourd'hui sont disponibles
dans les pannes privées des ménages nous
devons pouvoir en libérer 5 milliards
pour accélérer la décarbonation
évidemment une fois que nous aurons
libéré on ne s'invente pas on ne se
réinvente pas nous devons aussi protéger
et protéger c'est la commande publique
une révolution copernicienne culturelle
de notre manière de faire de la commande
publique de manière à privilégier des
achats responsables des achats durables
c'est possible c'est possible grâce au
dispositions que nous allons et que
j'espère vous allez voter dans ce texte
enfin vous le savez ça nous a été
suffisamment reproché en commission nous
n'avons pas traité directement des
enjeux de formation qui sont pour autant
essentiels pour le développement de
l'industrie française vous savez qu'ils
sont traités par ailleurs France 2030
c'est 750 millions d'euros sur un appel
à manifestation d'intérêt de compétences
et métiers d'avenir la réforme des
lycées professionnels l'accroissement
des places dans les écoles d'ingénieurs
tout ça va concourir à ce que nous
disposions de l'ensemble des forces
villes qui nous permettront de mettre en
oeuvre ce projet
et donc au fond ce projet de loi il vise
à rassembler les forces autour d'une
cause commune on l'a vu au Sénat en
commission et en hémicycle on l'a vu
aussi lors de la commission spéciale
nous sommes capables de nous rassembler
nous avons adopté vous avez adopté des
amendements venus de tous les bancs
256 amendements adoptés si j'ai bien
compté monsieur le Président en
provenance de tous les grands et donc
malgré ses votes qui montrent à la fois
la confiance la capacité de la plupart
des députés à se retrouver derrière ce
texte je dois avouer madame chikiro que
j'ai été un peu surpris de vous voir
déposer une motion de rejet préalable
sur ce texte j'espère évidemment qu'elle
sera rejetée tout simplement pour que
nous puissions continuer à débattre pour
que nous puissions continuer à enrichir
ce texte j'en suis convaincu sotex peut
nous rassembler il va permettre de
réconcilier économie écologique fin du
monde et fin du mois réconcilier la
France des territoires vous êtes
tellement prévisible tellement fragile
réconcilier la France des territoires
avec emploi et prospérité pour toutes
époustours
restaurer durablement notre balance
commerciale retrouver nos souveraineté
pouvoir imposer nos normes sociales et
environnementales quand d'autres ne le
respectent pas au fond rassembler la
France autour d'un projet commun
fabriqué en France durable et prospère
merci mesdames et messieurs les députés
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le ministre pour 5
minutes la parole est au rapporteur
général de la commission spéciale
c'est-à-dire au président kasbariian
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le Président de la
commission spéciale Mesdames et
Messieurs le rapporteur chers collègues
l'industrie fait battre le cœur de nos
territoires chacun d'entre nous a
régulièrement l'occasion d'aller visiter
les usines et les sites de production
qui maillent nos circonscriptions
d'aller à la rencontre des salariés et
des chefs d'entreprise qui travaillent
et font respirer le poumon industriel de
notre pays chacun a l'occasion de voir
la fierté de ces femmes et de ses hommes
qui travaillent sur des machines qui
sont autant de concentrés de technologie
et de savoir-faire acquis au fil du
temps ces déplacements et ses rencontres
font d'être en nous un sentiment de
fierté et d'espérance vis-à-vis de notre
industrie
alors qu'il a trop longtemps été
délaissé et dénigré nous nous devons de
soutenir massivement notre secteur
industriel et l'accompagner pour réduire
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre le
gouvernement et la majorité
présidentielle y travaillent sans
discontinuer depuis 2017 car une
industrie forte c'est plus d'emplois
dans nos territoires et l'assurance d'un
maintien de nos savoir-faire une
industrie forte c'est également une
contribution essentielle à l'économie
nationale et à notre balance commerciale
une industrie forte c'est aussi une
alliée indispensable à l'atteinte de nos
objectifs climatiques car l'industrie
c'est peut-être 20% de nos émissions
mais c'est surtout 100% des solutions
grâce à notre mix énergétique déjà très
décarbonée et elle a relocalisation de
certaines de nos productions nous
pouvons être l'un des premiers acteurs
de la transition écologique la France
est le pays le plus attractif d'Europe
en matière d'investissement étrangers et
ouvre désormais plus d'usines qu'elle
n'enferme il nous faut aller encore plus
loin et répondre aux attentes du terrain
qui n'a jamais entendu un dirigeant
d'entreprise lui dire dans nos
circonscriptions je souhaite implanter
ma nouvelle usine en France mais c'est
toujours plus compliqué et plus long
chez nous que chez nos voisins avec ce
projet de loi nous leur répondons en
parallélisant les procédures pour
diviser par deux les délais
d'implantation des projets industriels
qui n'a jamais entendu un élu local lui
dire j'ai une friche sur mon territoire
mais je ne peux pas la mettre à
disposition d'un projet industriel car
le coût de dépollution est beaucoup trop
élevé avec ce projet de loi nous
facilitons la dépollution et la
réhabilitation des friches pour libérer
davantage de fonciers industriels qui
n'a jamais entendu un salarié lui dire
nous venons de perdre un appel d'offres
car la collectivité ou l'Etat a préféré
choisir un produit fabriqué à l'autre
bout du monde car il était moins cher
avec ce projet de loi nous améliorons la
prise en compte des critères
environnementaux dans la commande
publique pour soutenir les entreprises
les plus vertueuses et leurs salariés
enfin qui n'a jamais entendu un Français
lui dire j'aimerais soutenir davantage
le fabriquer en France et la transition
écologique avec mon épargne mais je ne
sais pas comment faire avec ce projet de
loi nous leur proposons un nouveau plan
d'épargne à venir climat pour financer
les fonds propres de nos entreprises et
répondre à leurs attentes
chers collègues voilà tout le sens de ce
projet de loi apporter des solutions
concrètes à des problèmes concrets car
oui l'industrie permet de réconcilier
économie et écologie aux partisans de la
décroissance à ceux qui considèrent
qu'il faudrait moins de production et
donc moins d'usine et moins d'emplois
industriels dans notre pays je répondrai
que c'est au contraire par l'innovation
par l'investissement par la production
dans notre pays que nous réussirons à
répondre à l'urgence climatique notre
modèle français doit être celui de la
décarbonation de l'indépendance et de la
fierté industrielle je pense que nous
sommes nombreux à partager cette
ambition avant de conclure je souhaite
remercier l'ensemble des députés des
sénateurs des dirigeants d'entreprises
désorganisations professionnelles des
associations environnementales et des
salariés pour le travail de
co-construction qui a été engagé depuis
le mois de janvier par Bruno Le Maire et
Roland Lescure nous pouvons nous réjouir
collectivement d'avoir fait atterrir ce
texte dans les meilleures conditions et
c'est pourquoi je ne doute pas qu'il
sera voté dans une large majorité et que
nous arrivons ensemble à dérouler le
tapis vert à l'industrie française je
vous remercie
merci
pour 5 minutes la parole est à Madame
Christine de Cox rapporteur de la
commission spéciale
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le Président de la
commission spéciale mes chers collègues
en ma qualité de députés de Dunkerque je
suis très honoré d'apporter ma modeste
humble contribution au projet de loin
industrie verte pour trois raisons la
première parce que la fille de la
chirurgie se licencia 50 ans que je suis
a connu la décroissance industrielle de
son territoire et ses multiples
conséquences économiques sociales
familiale humaine traversait une ville
morte au milieu des années 80 pour aller
au lycée chaque jour voilà fermeture des
chantiers de France en 1988 malgré 325
navires lancés et un savoir-faire
reconnu mondialement marquage à jamais
parce qu'aujourd'hui Dunkerque est un
territoire comme ses habitants forts
endurant et résistant qui connaît un
fabuleux renouveau industriel au cœur de
l'industrie des carbonée avec à la clé
20.000 emplois directs troisièmement
parce que je porte tout effort la
volonté de donner aux femmes toutes
leurs places dans l'industrie et
n'apportant progrès ont été réalisés sur
le sujet particulièrement à Dunkerque je
lui chaque jour à travers ma présidence
de l'association entreprenante quel
bonheur pour des conseillers Mission
Locale de pouvoir donner à des jeunes et
particulièrement à des jeunes femmes des
perspectives positives et dynamiques en
matière de formation et d'emplois ce
n'était pas le cas il y a encore 5 ans
l'industrie c'est aussi un projet social
ne l'oublions jamais notre
responsabilité d'élus et d'encourager au
maximum la réindustrialisation
décarbonée de notre pays faisant plus
vite tout en faisant mieux
passons de 18 mois 9 mois comme le
préconisé dès janvier 2022 le rapport de
Monsieur Laurent Guillot intitulé
simplifié et accélérer les implantations
de l'activité économique en France
soulignant ainsi le retard de la France
par rapport à ses voisins européens pour
ce faire l'article 2 du projet de loi
propose d'accélérer la procédure de
délivrance de l'autorisation
environnementale tout en modernisant la
consultation du public cet article
prévoit un déroulement simultané des
phases d'examen du dossier de demande
d'autorisation d'une part et de
consultation du public d'autre part
c'est de façon actuellement
distinctes et successives mais surtout
l'article 2 crée une nouvelle procédure
de consultation du public celui-ci sera
désormais consulté dès le début de la
phase d'examen et pendant une période de
trois mois contre un mois aujourd'hui
dans leur cadre de l'enquête publique en
permettant au public de participer au
processus décisionnel en matière
d'environnement dès le début de la
procédure
c'est à dire lorsque toutes les options
et solutions sont encore possibles cette
nouvelle procédure de consultation du
public garantit un meilleur respect de
la Charte de l'environnement de 2004 je
souhaite saluer ici les apports du Sénat
qui ont permis d'améliorer de préciser
cette nouvelle procédure de consultation
du public ainsi afin de ne laisser aucun
citoyen sur le côté
le Sénat a fait introduit que le public
pouvait faire parvenir ses observations
et ses propositions par voie postale et
pas seulement par courrier électronique
la chambre haute a également souhaité
maintenir l'obligation pour le
commissaire enquêteur de figurer sur une
liste d'aptitude ce qui est gage de
compétences et d'impartialité la
commission spéciale également permis de
renforcer l'article 2 je pense en
particulier à la possibilité pour le
juge de condamner à des dommages et
intérêts les auteurs de recours abusifs
contre des décisions d'autorisation
environnementales j'en viens maintenant
à l'article 3 qui concerne la phase
amont de la procédure d'autorisation
environnementale il s'inscrit dans le
prolongement de la loi ASAP
d'accélération et de simplification de
l'action publique qui a ouvert la
possibilité de mutualiser les procédures
de participation du public dans le cadre
des projets d'implantation de parc
éolien en mer sur une même façade
maritime
ce principe est étendu par l'article 3 à
la demande de la personne publique qui
peut être le préfet une collectivité
territoriale l'organisation d'un débat
global ou d'une concertation globale est
en effet pertinente pour les projets
envisagés au sein d'une même zone à
forte activité industrielle comme par
exemple les zones industries au Portugal
je précise néanmoins que le caractère
facultatif de cette médiation est
conservée cet article 3 a fait l'objet
d'ajustement en commission spéciale
permettant à la fois une meilleure prise
en compte de l'accélération des impacts
liés au dérèglement climatiques et une
plus grande cohérence avec l'arsenal
législatif existant enfin le chapitre 2
du titre premier comportait un article 2
bis ajoute à l'initiative du Sénat il
prévoyait de mettre en place des délais
maximum pour l'instruction des projets
de déploiement d'énergie renouvelables
dans les zones d'accélération créées par
la loi du 10 mars 2023 relative à
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable la commission
spéciale a néanmoins supprimé cet
article ces dispositions relevées du
niveau réglementaire et posées par
ailleurs des problèmes d'articulation
avec le droit de l'Union européenne en
cours de modification sur ce sujet pour
conclure Jura affirmerai ma volonté de
non suppression de la CNDP mais au
contraire vous inviterez à la moderniser
merci de votre attention
merci madame la députée pour 5 minutes
la parole est à Madame Marie Agnès
poussiéventsback rapporteur de la
commission spéciale
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le Président de la
commission spéciale monsieur le
rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs chers collègues les
victoires et des boire du passé font
suite à de nombreuses et graves craintes
mais aussi à de grands et merveilleux
espoirs cette citation de Paul berocq
pourrait résumer l'histoire industrielle
et peut-être être le chapeau du projet
de loin industrie verte
comme il se dit beaucoup au café du
commerce ou ailleurs qu'ici dans cette
assemblée nous serions parfois un peu
déconnecté je voudrais vous dire que ce
projet de loi fait l'objet d'une très
grande concertation et que la méthode de
son élaboration est exemplaire merci
Monsieur Merci monsieur le ministre de
nous avoir permis de travailler de cette
manière je suis aujourd'hui heureuse
d'être co-rapporteur d'articles qui
demain seront utiles pour nos
industriels et donc pour l'emploi de nos
habitants je souhaite saluer également
la qualité des débats et le travail de
la commission spéciale qui aura permis
d'approfondir et d'améliorer
substantiellement les dispositions du
texte venons-en au texte dans son
chapitre 3 le projet de loi prévoit des
dispositions permettant d'encourager le
développement de l'économie circulaire
l'ambition de ce texte à travers
l'article 4 est forte puisque nous avons
voulu adapter les dispositions du code
de l'environnement pour permettre aux
entreprises d'utiliser plus facilement
des substances ou matériaux qui ne
deviendraient pas des déchets mais qui
étant utile rentrerai dans un processus
de fabrication de même nous avons voulu
encourager le recyclage de matériaux
incorporés dans des produits qui ne
prennent pas le statut de déchet cela
permet de réduire le recours à de la
matière première vierge et engendre des
réductions d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre en renforçant le recyclage et la
réutilisation
l'article 4 pour précisément sur le
statut du déchet il prévoit plusieurs
mesures parmi lesquelles la possibilité
au sein des plateformes industrielles
d'utiliser des résidus de production qui
sont présumées être des sous-produits et
non des déchets la clarification du
régime de sortie du statut des déchets
également la création d'un régime de
sanctions administrative applicables au
transfert transfont transfrontalier
pardon de déchets illégaux l'article 4
bis introduit par la commission spéciale
vis à rendre les sanctions pénales
applicables en cas d'affraction à la
législation sur les déchets plus
dissuasive afin notamment de lutter
contre le trafic illicite de déchets et
les filières il le chapitre 4 concerne
la réhabilitation des friches les
friches peuvent être des opportunités
pour les collectivités de construire sur
un sol déjà artificialisé face à la
réflexion des réserves foncières
disponibles et à l'obligation de
limitation de l'artificialisation des
sols nous avons un impératif faciliter
la réhabilitation des friches
aujourd'hui nous le savons tous le
parcours pour remobiliser ses friches et
trop complexes nous proposons plusieurs
évolutions pour le simplifier
l'article 6 réforme quant à lui le
mécanisme des garanties financières
obligatoires pour les
ICPE les plus polluantes en commission
spéciale nous avons supprimé un
dispositif qui n'a démontré aucune
efficacité depuis 10 ans il ne permet
pas aux pouvoirs publics de bénéficier
des financements nécessaires à la mise
en sécurité et la rubilégiation des
sites industriels concernés en
contrepartie parce qu'il y en a les
sanctions administratives et notamment
financières ont été renforcés dans les
cas d'exploitation sans autorisation
ou illégales
enfin l'article 7 est aussi ambitieux il
vise à faciliter encourager la mise en
oeuvre d'opérations de restauration de
la biodiversité de renaturation des
sites naturels dans les territoires
notamment à des fins de compensation
mais pas uniquement nous avons
requalifié le nouveau dispositif en
commission de site naturel de
compensation de restauration et de
dénaturation cette dénomination traduit
bien leur double vocation à la fois
faciliter la mise en oeuvre des
obligations de compensation et permettre
l'engagement volontaire d'acteurs de la
biodiversité je souhaite que nos débats
soient comme en commission spéciale
apaisée et tout simplement
productif merci monsieur le ministre
pour cette conclusion merci madame la
députée 5 minutes avec le rapporteur de
la commission spéciale under
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le Président de la
commission spéciale monsieur le
rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues
110 milliards d'euros c'est ce que
représente la commande publique en
France
110 milliards d'euros c'est un des
leviers opérationnels que nous vous
proposons d'actionner pour verdir notre
économie
à la fin de la précédente législature le
Parlement a adopté la loi climat et
résiliente qui a porté des évolutions
majeures dans notre droit de la commande
publique et dans le renforcement de sa
dimension écologique
nous sommes aujourd'hui quasiment à
mi-chemin de l'entrée en vigueur de sa
disposition la plus ambitieuse
comme prévu par l'article 35 de la Loi
climat et résilience d'ici l'été 2026
100% des marchés publics intégreront un
critère environnemental
d'ici à cette échéance il nous reste
encore du travail à accomplir pour que
les marchés publics puissent constituer
un levier massif et incontournable en
faveur de la transition écologique
c'est tout le sens du titre 2 que je
vous présente qui est consacré aux
enjeux environnementaux de la commande
publique
l'article 12 habilite le gouvernement à
introduire par ordonnance un nouveau
motif d'exclusion de la commande
publique en cas de non-respect de
l'obligation d'établir un rapport de
durabilité cette obligation est prévue
par la directive relative à la
publication d'information en matière de
durabilité par les entreprises dites
directives CSRD
il s'agit là d'un dispositif analogue à
celui qui avait été introduit par la loi
climat résilience à propos du plan de
vigilance des sociétés
l'article 13 qui occupera à juste titre
une place prédominante dans nos débats
comprend trois mesures principales
tout d'abord il poursuit le renforcement
d'espaceur schéma de promotion des
achats publics socialement et
écologiquement responsables dont
l'importance est primordiale pour
orienter l'évolution de la commande
publique ensuite il crée un nouveau
motif d'exclusion des marchés publics
pour le non-respect de l'obligation
d'établir un BGS bilan des missions de
gaz à effet de serre enfin il précise la
façon dont l'offre économiquement la
plus avantageuse et déterminée notamment
par la prise en compte du critère
environnemental cela dans l'attente de
l'entrée en vigueur de l'article 35 de
la Loi primaire résilience qui pourra
être anticipé pour certains marchés
l'article 14 enfin étant les
dispositions de ce même article et du
présent projet de loi dans les
collectivités d'outre-mer et en
Nouvelle-Calédonie
la discussion des séries s'est avéré
fructueuse je relève l'adoption le 3
dispositions additionnelles à
l'initiative du gouvernement
correspondant articles 12 bis 12 terres
et 12 quatters ces derniers introduisent
des exceptions au droit de la commande
publique dans des cas très spécifiques à
savoir les activités d'opérateur de
réseau il s'agit de prévenir les risques
d'infructuosité des marchés dans un
contexte économique marqué par la rareté
de l'offre par rapport à des besoins
croissants
nous ne sommes pas ici dans le cas des
marchés publics classiques auxquels
accède et doivent continuer d'accéder
nos entreprises locales le Sénat
également introduit un article 13 bisant
à favoriser le rétrofit dans le
renouvellement annuel des flottes de
véhicules des acheteurs publics la
discussion du projet de loi en
commission s'est avéré elle aussi très
utile nous avons tout d'abord enrichi en
plusieurs points le contenu de l'espace
vert afin de mieux les orienter vers la
prise en compte des critères
environnementaux j'ai également fait
adopter quatre amendements pour
renforcer l'obligation d'établir un BGS
aujourd'hui trop peu appliqué
ces amendements permettent d'utiliser
des leviers incitatifs et contraignants
tout en développant le recours du BG
simplifié
enfin à l'article 13 bis relatif au
rétrophyte il m'a paru préférable de
préciser que les véhicules rétrophités
des pris en compte dans les véhicules à
faible et à très faible émission plutôt
que d'imposer un seuil minimal de
recours à ce type de véhicule c'est ce
que souhaitait le Sénat de manière
prématurée et surtout inadaptée à
certaines fautes de véhicules publics
je suis convaincue que le texte y a été
adopté en commission soumis à notre
assemblée aujourd'hui est ambitieux il
est le juste équilibre entre les
avancées nécessaires à la transition
écologique et la capacité des acheteurs
publics et des entreprises à absorber de
nouvelles contraintes de fait je ne
doute pas
tout comme en commission que nos
discussions cette semaine seront
constructives seront constructives et
qu'elles permettront de tendre vers un
seul objectif le verdissement de la
commande publique je vous remercie
merci madame la députée nous poursuivons
avec 5 minutes pour le rapporteur
suivant de la commission spéciale
monsieur Damien Adam
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues pour mener
à bien la transition écologique dans
l'industrie est plus globalement dans
toute notre économie notre pays aura
besoin de ressources supplémentaires le
rapport pizani ferry Mahfouz diffusé il
y a quelques temps estimé ainsi que 66
milliards d'euros d'argent public et
privés seront nécessaires chaque année
en France pour atteindre les objectifs
climatiques que nous nous sommes fixés à
l'échelle européenne pour 2030 face à ce
défi pour répondre aux investissements
considérables que nécessitent la
transition écologique la France dispose
de deux atouts une épargne privée
considérable et un secteur financier
solide en effet les Français ont de
l’épargne en quantité entre les produits
réglementés et les produits de fonds
propres le patrimoine financier des
français a atteint 5600 milliards
d'euros au dernier trimestre 2022 ce qui
compte maintenant c'est d'orienter cette
épargne vers les investissements de la
transition lors du dernier mandat nous
avons proposé de premières avancées avec
notamment la loi pacte pour acc le
déploiement des labels imposer une prise
en compte des enjeux environnementaux
dans la gestion des sociétés et
renforcer l'épargne de long terme via
l'assurance vie le plan d'épargne en
action et en créant le plan d'épargne
retraite aujourd'hui nous devons aller
plus loin et faire un saut quantitatif
c'est tout l'objet du titre 3 de la loi
industrielle présentée ce jour certains
préféreront toujours la simplicité des
augmentations d'impôts ou de la dette en
plus pour répondre à l'enjeu du
financement de la transition écologique
nous nous pensons qu'un pays avec le
taux d'imposition le plus élevé du monde
et une dette de 3000 milliards d'euros
n'a pas besoin de plus d'impôts et de
dettes mais d'innover notamment avec des
produits d'épargne adaptés c'est fort de
ces constats avec Michel Polin délégué
général de voyage cloud j'ai piloté le
chantier financé l'industrie verte
française dans le cadre de la
consultation entamée le 5 janvier
dernier qui a permis de co-construire ce
projet de loi et qui se traduit par le
titre 3 de la loi que nous étudions
cette semaine nous avons conduit pendant
plusieurs semaines des dizaines
d'auditions de toutes les parties
prenantes du financement du monde
associatif en France pour réfléchir à
des mesures concrètes efficaces et
surtout réaliste pour réussir le
financement dans notre transition les
mesures de ce projet de loi nous
permettront de franchir de nouvelles
étapes et d’indre deux objectifs
développer des champions français de
l'Industrie de la transition et
accompagné toutes les entreprises
françaises dans leur décarbonation pour
cela nous continuons et accélérons la
politique de labellisation pour laquelle
nous sommes déjà une référence en Europe
le label ISR et le label ESG le plus
populaire d'Europe son encourt et de 777
milliards d'euros c'est 6 fois plus que
le deuxième label de sa catégorie nous
avons élargi en commission spéciale la
prise en compte des préférences en
matière de durabilité des souscripteurs
des plans d’épargne retraite un exemple
concret de cette label ISR et de cette
étanque extension de ce projet de loi
nous créons également dans ce projet de
loi le plan d'épargne avenir climat qui
offrira aux jeunes de notre pays un
produit en adéquation avec leur
engagement sur la position écologique
l'épargne des mineurs s'élève en France
à 40 milliards d'euros nous devons
maintenant orienter une plus grande part
de cette épargne vers la transition la
Commission a permis l'adoption
d'amendement qui clarifie notamment
cette orientation de plan d'appargne
avenir climat pour lever tout doute sur
le fait que sa finance véritablement la
transition écologique avec cette loi
nous favorisons également
l'investissement dans les
infrastructures les petites et moyennes
entreprises et les entreprises de taille
intermédiaires ce tissu qui nous est
indispensable pour réussir notre
décarbonation et la transition
écologique en même temps nous
élargissons l'horizon d'investissement
des épargnants français en adaptant les
règles applicables au contrat
d'assurance vie et au plan d'épargne
retraite les épargnants pourront ainsi
dans des conditions protectrices accéder
plus facilement à des placements au
couple rendement risque attractifs sur
ces points la commission spéciale a
adopté les amendements de clarification
et de simplification visant à préserver
la souplesse et assurer le caractère
opérationnel des dispositions prévues
par le texte enfin avec ce projet de loi
nous adoptons notre droit pour d'un même
coup renforcer l'attractivité de la
place de Paris et nous préparer au
déploiement des fonds européens
d'investissement de longue durée les
fameux elfes 2.0 que je sais vous aimez
particulièrement ce véhicule souple doit
nous permettre de lever 100 milliards
d'euros à l'horizon 2027 orienté vers un
ensemble précis d'émetteurs les petites
entreprises et les actifs réels dont les
contraintes de financement obèrent la
décarbonation et je me réjouis que nous
puissions être un des pays européens les
plus en avance sur la transposition de
ses ailes 2.0 dans notre droit national
pour conclure chers collègues j'en dirai
que si la transition écologique est une
nécessité son financement est
indispensable et grâce à ce projet de
loi nous en faisons également un atout
d'attractivité et de croissance pour
notre pays et nous pouvons tous nous
réjouir que l'industrie soit redevenue
une priorité nationale et que nous
puissions noter des dispositions qui
permettront de réindustrialiser dans
tout nos territoires de créer des usines
de créer des emplois durables et de
faire en sorte que nous puissions demain
avoir une économie prospère je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Charles
rapporteur pour observation de la
commission des affaires européennes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le Président la
Commission spéciale monsieur le
rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs chers collègues la
commission des affaires européennes
s'est saisie pour observation de ce
projet de loi considérant que
l'industrie fait partie des sujets
d'intérêt majeurs pour affirmer la
puissance de l'Union européenne
il faut saluer l'ambition de ce texte
qui s'inscrit dans la volonté de
l'Europe d'être le leader mondial de la
transition écologique sur la base de
deux orientations la sobriété et
l'innovation les Européens n'ont pas à
rougir de leur bilan car notre continent
est déjà à l'avant-garde de la
transition le green futur index est un
classement établi par le prestigieux
Massachusetts of technologies le MIT et
ce classement mesure la capacité des
pays à construire une économie
soutenable et bas carbone 8 des 10
premiers pays du classement sont
européens dont 6 membres de l'Union
européenne la France et neuvième a noté
que les États-Unis ne se que 19e et la
Chine 27e c'est donc un fait reconnu que
l'Europe a pris de l'avance dans le
pivotage indispensable de nos économies
vers des modèles plus respectueux de
l'environnement le pacte vert lancé en
décembre 2019 par la Commission
européenne en est l'illustration
ambitieuse
cette avance que nous avons en Europe il
faut la conserver et même la creuser si
les États-Unis ont remporté de façon
incontestable l'avait révolution
numérique de la fin du 20e siècle et ce
sont assurés par ce fait une longue
domination économique dans le monde
l'Europe peut et doit remporter la
révolution écologique qui s'amorce
ceux qui domineront les technologies de
la décarbonation les entreprises qui
seront leader de l'industrie verte
seront les géants économiques de demain
et moi je veux que ces technologies
soient le fruit du génie de notre
continent quelle sorte d'élaboratoires
et des usines d'Europe
chers collègues ce texte renouvelle
aussi l'ambition de la majorité de
réindustrialiser la France après des
décennies de sabordage de notre outil
productif ça a été rappelé par les
ministres et de renoncement devant le
mirage d'une économie tout service
soyons lucides là aussi notre pays a
encore du retard à rattraper
l'industrie représente 24% de la
richesse de l'Union en 2022 mais
seulement 17% de celle de la France
quand elle est de 30% pour la Pologne
27% pour l'Allemagne 23% pour l'Italie
tout cela pour dire que si nous voulons
industrialiser durablement notre pays
l'effort entamé de en 2017 devra être
poursuivi avec constance pendant
longtemps encore
les décennies d'hémorragie de notre
industrie nous pouvons être fiers avec
la majorité le président de la
République de les avoir stoppés
nous avons montré qu'il n'y avait pas de
fatalité à la désindustrialisation
lorsqu'une politique économique
favorable aux entrepreneurs est mener
baisse de la fiscalité sur le capital
baisse des impôts de production plan
d'action pour la croissance et la
transformation des entreprises
ordonnance travail ces réformes ne sont
pas étrangères au fait que depuis 2017
la France recrée de l'emploi industriel
et qu'il s'ouvre plus de nouvelles
usines qu'il s'enferment
sur un plan plus technique pour en finir
j'ai déjà précisé un certain nombre de
choses en commission et dans le rapport
écrit je voudrais simplement rappeler
trois la première je veux dire la
satisfaction de voir l'ambition de
réduire les délais d'installation des
sites industriels la France pêche sur ce
point en Europe et je peux le dire comme
député frontière et de l'Allemagne nous
sommes effectivement pas bons mais je
m'adresse là au ministre les services
des concentrés de l'État devront suivre
pour faciliter les procédures
administratives parce qu'il y a parfois
un décalage entre ce qui est dit à Paris
et ce qui est dans les faits exécuté par
les administrations
départementale deuxième point
l'introduction de critères
environnementaux dans les marchés
publics est une bonne chose
nous devons renforcer la préférence
européenne elle est déjà possible sur la
défense la sécurité les opérateurs de
réseau alors pourquoi ne pas ne pas les
tendre aux technologies vertes sans
bâtir de sans parler de bâtir un jour ce
fameux bail européen actes que nous
appelons toujours de nos vœux troisième
point il vautrons le crédit d'impôt
investissement industrie verte c'est un
citation fiscale simple s'appuie sur des
dispositifs de la Commission européenne
que la France a aidé à concevoir et que
la France sera la première à notifier il
faudra peut-être dans quelques années en
2025 étant de le champ de ce crédit
d'impôt mais c'est un bon début et nous
devons là le féliciter en conclusion
messieurs les mini chers collègues ce
projet de loi est utile à la France il
est utile à l'Europe il est utile à la
planète c'est donc un bon texte il faut
le soutenir je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député
j'ai reçu de Madame Mathilde de panneau
et des membres du groupe la France
insoumise une motion de rejet préalable
déposant l'application de l'article 91
alinéa 5 du règlement et cette notion
est défendue par Madame Sofia shikiru
pour une durée maximum de 15 minutes
elle a la parole
[Applaudissements]
je saurais pas le faire
merci ça va aller
monsieur le Président collègue messieurs
les ministres en janvier 2023 vous nous
aviez promis une grande loi pour engager
la France dans la réindustrialisation et
dans une nouvelle révolution celle de
l'industrie verte aujourd'hui ce que
nous avons entre les mains n'est ni une
grande loi ni une stratégie de
planification et encore moins une
politique de réindustrialisation
écologique ce que vous nous demandez de
voter est encore et toujours la même
recette
inefficace depuis 20 ans et qui consiste
à distribuer de l'argent public aux
entreprises en espérant relancer la
croissance sans contrepartie sans
contrôle sans obligation sur la réalité
de la décarbonation comme si l'État
n'avait pas depuis plus de 20 ans
gaspiller des milliards d'euros au nom
de l'attractivité et de la compétitivité
pour quel résultat en
202263,6 milliards d'euros de déficit
dont 78,5 milliards d'euros pour les
seuls produits manufacturés la part de
l'industrie manufacturière dans le PIB
est passé de 24% en 80 à 9% aujourd'hui
et ce sont 2,5 millions d'emplois qui
ont ainsi disparu en réalité ce que vous
faites avec ce projet de loi c'est un
pari des parieurs accro aux jeux du
marché sauf que vous pariez avec
l'argent des Français sur la main
invisible du marché une main invisible
qui est à l'origine du saccage de la
planète et de la sixième extinction des
espèces oui moi je le dis très
clairement le changement climatique et
la conséquence directe du productivisme
et de la course folle de la croissance
infinie déjà près de la moitié de
l'humanité 3,6 milliards de personnes
vivent dans des contextes hautement
vulnérables au changement climatique
c'est le GIEC qui le dit la main
invisible du marché c'est la main qui
est à l'origine de l'explosion de la
pauvreté et des inégalités dans le monde
c'est une main invisible qui prend
beaucoup
200 milliards d'euros chaque année dans
notre pays en subvention en crédit
d'impôts en suppression de taxes et de
cotisations sociales c'est une invisible
qui nous tue nous les travailleurs le
sang et les larmes des travailleurs et
des chômeurs des gens trop fatigués
malades mais que vous allez forcer à
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans vous vous
présentez donc devant nous messieurs les
ministres avec une promesse que vous ne
tiendrez pas nous le savons et vous le
savez vous savez très bien que les
grandes entreprises vont prendre
l'argent un maximum d'argent et puis
c'est tout vous les avez vu faire plus
d'une fois encaisser l'argent public
fermez les usines se sauver avec les
brevets avec les machines mettre au
chômage des centaines de travailleurs
Monsieur le Maire
quand vous adressez à l'un des grands
timoniaux de l'industrie française là le
sur Guillaume Faury et que vous lui
dites la seule chose que je vous demande
c'est d'accorder une attention toute
particulière à tout le tissu industriel
des sous-traitants présents en Occitanie
et par toi ailleurs en France vous savez
bien n'est-ce pas qu'il ne fera rien
vous savez bien qu'il ne vous écoutera
pas
vous suppliques au patron font pitié
Monsieur le Maire elles sont même
gênantes pour nous un ministre aussi
puissant en place depuis 2017 qui en est
ainsi réduit à supplier les patrons
voilà les principales et le début des
raisons de cette motion de rejet ce que
nous voulons faire monsieur le ministre
c'est vous donner du courage au lieu
d'abdiquer devant l'ampleur de la tâche
nous voulons vous aider à agir car nous
n'avons plus de temps à perdre
que s'est-il passé depuis le 15 mars
2023 Monsieur Bruno Le Maire dans une
vidéo sur Youtube qui a été vu par 1500
personnes c'est pas mal vous nous
promettiez une loi avec des mesures sur
la fiscalité sur la formation sur la
commande publique sur la réglementation
sur le made in France qu'est-ce qu'il
s'est donc passé pour que l'on se
retrouve avec un pauvre texte de trois
volets 19 articles
il n'y a rien sur la fiscalité rien sur
la formation rien non plus sur le
fabriqué en France pas même à la belle
et ce qu'il contient sur la commande
publique et la réglementation
permettez-moi de vous le dire ça ne va
pas dans le bon sens vous savez mieux
que moi à quel point la commande
publique est importante était un levier
essentiel de notre économie en 2022
c'est 95 milliards d'euros la commande
publique vous ne faites rien pour
réorienter cette commande publique
massive alors même qu'elle présente
aujourd'hui au moins de limites au moins
deux la première c'est que seulement 30%
des marchés publics vont à des PME qui
sont des entreprises territoriales
ancrées dans les territoires ce sont
essentiellement les grandes entreprises
qui profitent de la commande publique or
on a un problème avec nos grandes
entreprises en France c'est qu'elles
sont à l'origine des délocalisations
depuis 20 ou 30 ans c'est qu'elles sont
très importatrice est très peu
exportatrice puisqu'en l'espace de 10
ans entre 2012 et 2022 la part du PIB de
leurs exportations est passé de 4% à
deux pour cent un autre problème avec
les la commande publique ce sont les
clauses d'environnementales les clauses
environnementales en 2021 c'est moins de
19% des marchés publics qui en
contenaient au moins une vous auriez pu
profiter de ce projet de loi de cette
loi pour introduire des critères
géographiques environnementaux et
sociaux pour limiter les importations
pour que l'argent des Français du
contribuables cessent d'aller à
l'étranger et qu'il profite au contraire
à la production locale vous auriez pu
comme nous le proposons nous
conditionner les marchés publics à la
fourniture d'un plan quinquennal déco
conception pour toutes les entreprises
de plus de 250 salariés vous refuser
absolument tous nos amendements qui vont
en ce sens
vous pouvez applaudir merci
un autre volet de ce texte c'est la
simplification de la réglementation
écoutez monsieur les ministres nous ne
sommes pas dupe la seule chose que vous
prévoyez de réduire c'est les contrôles
ce sont les contrôles sur les impacts
environnementaux et sur la consultation
publique qui sont pourtant les seuls
garants de ne pas faire n'importe quoi
mais soyons sérieux ce que vous faites
là ça s'appelle un cash misère si vous
écoutez les investisseurs parmi les
premières raisons dans leur choix
d'installation il y a quoi il y a le
coût de l'énergie la France a
considérablement perdu en attractivité
de ce point de vue là avec l'explosion
des prix de l'énergie vous refusez de
mettre en oeuvre la seule mesure qui
nous ferait gagner un avantage
concurrentiel majeur celui du retour au
tarif réglementé de l'électricité que
nous avons voté ici même voilà le seul
vrai sujet
il reste la question du financement de
cette grande transition écologique de
l'industrie et là encore que de
renoncement Monsieur le Maire vous
refusez de t'accélérer pourtant les
riches ce sont les premiers pollueurs un
riche européen pollue 6 fois plus qu'un
pauvre européen
vous promettez un énième crédit d'impôt
à l'automne qui passera coup de 49,3
anti-démocratique pour ce qui est du
financement privé d'abord dans un
premier temps vous nous avez parlé des
140 milliards du livret de développement
durable et solidaire vous y avez renoncé
même ça vous ne voulez pas y toucher
vous auriez pu toucher à l'assurance vie
un encourt actuellement de près de 1900
milliards d'euros vous auriez pu dire
tiens nous allons conditionner les
avantages fiscaux des assurances vie à
des investissements dans l'industrie
verte ou dans les énergies renouvelables
mais non hélas hélas rien de tout ça ce
que vous avez décidé de faire vous
Monsieur le Maire parce que vous avez
énormément d'ambition vous avez décidé
de créer un livret d'épargne pour les
enfants de riches un plan d'épargne à
venir climat pour des mineurs que vos
députés ici présents défendent en nous
disant que c'est important pour les
parents et les grands-parents de pouvoir
mettre de l'argent de côté pour leurs
enfants en sont exclus bien sûr de cet
avenir climat les adultes absolument pas
d'enfants passons mais surtout en sont
exclus les enfants qui n'ont pas
d'adultes assez fortunés autour d'eux
pour se permettre de mettre de l'argent
sur un compte bloqué c'est une mesure
qui est injuste qui est inégalitaire et
je suis prête à parier que c'est une
mesure qui ne vise qu'un seul objectif
de l'optimisation fiscale et de la
défiscalisation on ne peut pas se
réjouir de cette situation la France
insoumise publie aujourd'hui un
contre-projet nous avons tenu à vous
démontrer que nous sommes capables de
faire mieux que vous et nous sommes
d'ailleurs j'en profite monsieur le
ministre vous je vous vois en train
d'écrire j'en profite pour vous dire que
vous avez eu l'amabilité de nous
recevoir nous les députés insoumis et
c'est suffisamment rare actuellement
avec ce gouvernement d'être reçu et
écouter pour que je le souligne donc
nous avons voulu vous présenter un
contre projet c'est un contre projet que
nous avons voulu comme le vôtre assez
court résultat il comporte 75 mesures
c'est-à-dire presque fois plus que le
vôtre notre projet commence par définir
quelque chose de très simple il commence
par définir l'industrie verte c'est en
effet une des incongruités de votre
projet de loi vous refusez
catégoriquement de définir l'industrie
verte alors même que cela donne son
titre à votre loi cela fait dire à plein
de gens qu'il s'agit de greenwashing
parce que la réalité de votre projet de
loi c'est que des entreprises
productives polluantes pourront
prétendre à bénéficier des dispositifs
de ce texte alors même que leur démarche
de décarbonation ne sera ni effective ni
contrôlé de plus vous partez de l'idée
que l'industrie verte se réduit à un
sujet de décarbonation et de
compensation des émissions carbone nous
défendons une autre vision notre projet
c'est l'industrie verte est une
industrie de la sobriété c'est une
industrie de l'éco-conception qui limite
son impact sur la biodiversité sur les
lots et sur les sols elle suppose donc
et c'est la base
de limiter les volumes importés donc de
limiter les émissions carbone importées
il faut jouer sur la structure de la
balance commerciale il faut aussi jouer
et réduire considérablement les déchets
industriels en limitant la surproduction
et en permettant le recyclage la
récupération des déchets industriels
nous proposons monsieur le ministre la
mise en place de planquinquennaux des
co-conception et d'élargir cette
obligation à toutes les filières parce
qu'ils existent déjà pour un certain
nombre de filières et nous proposons que
toutes les entreprises de plus de 250
salariés soient concernés l'industrie
verte c'est aussi une industrie qui nous
oblige à une gestion durable
du transport donc à une logistique verte
d'où notre proposition de reconnaître le
statut de déchet des emballages
logistiques
je vais passer à un sujet qui est aussi
un des grands absents de votre texte de
loi qui est celui de la planification
vous savez nous les insoumis nous nous y
connaissons en planification écologique
parce qu'il se trouve que depuis 15 ans
c'est nous qui défendons cette idée là
et c'est nous qui l'avons porté dans le
débat public avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon je
vous passe toutes les railleries de
votre camp puisque aujourd'hui vous avez
adopté notre sémantique mais vous n'êtes
pas allé jusqu'à adopter notre programme
et le concept lui-même qui prévoit la
planification écologique une
organisation démocratique qui implique
les salariés et qui implique les
citoyens ce sont deux sujets tabous de
votre projet de loi
je vais passer rapidement sur la
formation vous savez que nous les
insoumis nous sommes de grands
défenseurs des lycées professionnels
d'un bac professionnel à 4 ans et de cap
en trois ans nous voulons des métiers
qui répondent aux besoins écologiques je
passe aussi rapidement compte tenu du
temps sur la question du financement
mais je peux pas passer à côté du
rapport de la Cour des comptes monsieur
Lescure Monsieur Bruno Le Maire vous
m'aviez fait la promesse en commission
des affaires économiques d'évaluer les
aides publiques la Cour des comptes vous
dit très clairement elle vous demande de
limiter la durée des aides de prévoir
leur évaluation de mieux évaluer les
besoins des entreprises et la nécessité
même de la dépense elle vous demande de
systématiser les outils de contrôle a
priori nous sommes en accord avec 100%
des recommandations de la Cour des
comptes et je vais dire une chose il va
de votre crédibilité de supprimer les
niches fiscales brunes j'arrive au terme
de mon intervention
ne vous réjouissez pas trop vite notre
vision pour une bifurcation écologique
et très franchement proactif
contrairement à la vôtre oui nous
pensons que notre pays est capable de
réduire sa dépendance au réseau
d'approvisionnement internationaux
d'instaurer la conditionnalité
social et environnemental des aides
publiques et de mettre en place un
protectionnisme solidaire c'est-à-dire
de protéger les filières du dumping et
d'élargir le mécanisme d'ajustement
carbone au frontières je demande à tous
mes collègues ici de rejeter ce texte de
loi d'industrie verte parce qu'une autre
politique est possible j'aurais
peut-être souhaité proposer une motion
de renvoi mais vous allez supprimer la
procédure car ce texte mériterait d'être
considérablement retravaillé sinon si la
motion de rejet n'était pas adoptée je
vous demande au moins de voter le
rétablissement des articles supprimés le
premier bis A et le 4a le premier
permettait au moins de définir une
stratégie nationale pour l'industrie
verte la base la base d'un tel projet de
loi le second permettait de planifier
localement à l'échelle des bassins
économiques par la création de projets
territoriaux d'industrie circulaire ces
deux articles que vous avez fait
supprimer en commission spéciale sont
les seuls à poser des bases solides pour
l'avenir le reste ce que vous nous
présentez ez là Monsieur le Maire ne
changera strictement rien merci
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la députée
monsieur le ministre le maire vous avez
la parole
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les député madame le député
Shiki rouge voit que le projet de loin
industrie verte vous avez mis en forme
ce dont je me réjouis vous avez dit que
notre recette industrielle était
inefficace elle est peut-être inefficace
mais elle donne depuis 7 ans des
résultats comme nous n'avons pas obtenu
depuis 3 décennies dans notre pays nous
avons créé 100000 points industriels je
le rappelle nous avons ouvert 300 usines
nous avons obtenu 13 milliards d'euros
d'investissement étrangers pour cette
seule année sur le site de Dunkerque on
refuse des investissements là où c'est
la désindustrialisation qui avait semé
la pauvreté la misère et le désarroi
nous pouvons être fiers nous tous ici
d'avoir réussi la réindustrialisation de
territoire entier par notre politique
votre politique celle que vous proposez
madame chikiro est un repoussoir la
nôtre attire les investisseurs vous
faites peur nous rassurer voilà toute la
différence entre nos politiques
vous nous dites que la politique
industrielle française a mené un
effondrement de l'industrie de 24 à 11%.
c'est vrai mais c'est le produit de
cette même politique qui a été adoptée
depuis plusieurs décennies
singulièrement depuis 1981 plus de taxes
plus d'impôts moins de richesse moins de
salariés moins d'usine moins de
travailleurs moins d'ouvriers voilà la
réalité de cette politique que nous
avons combattue nous nous avons eu le
courage en 2017 avec cette majorité avec
le président de la République de baisser
la fiscalité sur le capital parce qu'il
n'y a pas d'industrie sans capital et
qu'il n'y a pas de renforcement de
l'industrie sans attractivité j'en
fiscalité compétitive et sans impôts de
production qui baisse qui était 7 fois
plus élevé en France qu'en Allemagne
nous avons baissé les impôts de
production dans notre pays et nous avons
désormais comme objectif de ramener la
part de l'industrie dans le PNB de 11 à
15% dans les industries qui viennent
vous êtes permis de vous en prendre au
directeur général d'Airbus Guillaume
Faury je ne suis pas là pour défendre
quelques directeurs générales que je
sois je rappelle juste madame Chikirou
que Guillaume Faury a plus créé d'emploi
industriels en une seule décision que
vous en 50 déclarations
qu'il a signé avec le soutien du
gouvernement français Madame Chikirou il
a signé le plus grand contrat il a signé
le plus grand contrat de l'histoire de
l'aéronautique avec un compagnie
indienne indigo je vous reconnais une
certaine cohérence là dedans vous nous
avez critiqué de recevoir le Premier
ministre indien nous nous recevons le
Premier ministre indien et nous signons
le plus grand contrat de l'histoire
aéronautique avec la compagnie indienne
indigo vous faites peur nous rassurons
nous créons des richesses et vous les
détruisez voilà toute la différence
entre nos deux politiques
dieu soit loué et Madame Chikirou vous
n'êtes pas directeur général d'Airbus
vous êtes député la France insoumise et
député la France insoumise voulait être
totalement entièrement singulièrement
dans votre ton dans votre raisonnement
dans vos propositions dans vos envolés
lyriques qui Florent bon la contrainte
et le refus de toute liberté nous ici
nous restons attachés à la liberté la
liberté de l'économie la liberté des
entreprises la liberté des citoyens et
la liberté de la politique
vous avez proposé un contre-projet votre
contre-projet c'est toujours la même
cible les riches et les entreprises
c'est toujours la même proposition des
taxes et des impôts c'est toujours la
même méthode la contrainte et
obligations c'est toujours le même
modèle le gosse plan vous pourriez faire
un copyright pour tout votre propre
projet politique ce serait une économie
de papier ce serait une économie
d'énergie ce serait une économie de
temps dans ce serait très bien pour tous
les députés ici et ce serait très bien
pour la planète
merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur millienne
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le rapport en général
Mesdames et Messieurs le rapporteur moi
encore une fois madame chikiri je suis
comme d'habitude assez estomaqué que
vous déposiez des motion
non non non non non non non franchement
non franchement non franchement non j'ai
je peux avoir des admirations mais pas
pour vous
donc assez estomac ne cédait pas à
toutes les provocations déposer une
motion de rejet il n'y a pas un texte
pas un texte que nous étudions dans
cette émission sans qu'il y ait une
motion de rejet déposée par la France
insoumise pour le parti le plus
démocratique d'après vous de cette
assemblée c'est quand même un peu
étrange vous ne voulez pas débattre vous
ne voulez pas débattre donc ça je trouve
ça très étrange première chose deuxième
chose je trouve très étrange que vous le
fassiez sur ce texte là parce que
excusez-moi vous comme moi vous comme
moi nous étions en commission et nous
avons discuté et des fois nous avons
même trouvé oh pas souvent quelques
terrains d'entente mais nous en avons
trouvé quand même pas souvent mais
quelques fois on en a trouvé et puis ce
qui m'inquiète le plus c'est que là on
parle de quoi de l'industrie de demain
de l'industrie verte de demain de
l'industrie qui va nous falloir mettre
en place et j'ai peut-être vous
apprendre quelque chose parce que si
vous fréquentez beaucoup les syndicats
je ne crois pas que vous ferez candiez
beaucoup les chefs d'entreprise et c'est
dommage et c'est dommage parce que
l'économie circulaire l'économie de la
fonctionnalité toute cette économie
qu'on va être obligée de mettre en place
demain il ne vous en pas attendu madame
Chikirou pour la demander ils sont déjà
en train de la faire renseignez-vous un
petit peu et vous verrez que tout ça
évolue au point que nous allons sûrement
devoir retravailler nos modèles de
l'économie circulaire donc l'industrie
verte est en marche et nous le demande
tous les jours quant au texte vous nous
avez reproché deux points 1 que les
propositions fiscales n'étaient pas dans
le texte que nous étions aujourd'hui
même chez qui ça fait longtemps que vous
êtes ici vous savez très bien que les
propositions fiscales seront étudiées
dans le projet de loi de finances
d'accord la deuxième la deuxième chose
la formation il y a un texte sur la
formation professionnelle qui arrive il
est normal que soit étudié la formation
dans ce texte là et enfin il y a un
élément et pourtant j'ai communiqué la
note de cadrage à tous les présidents de
groupe de cette assemblée
même madame panot comme quoi je suis pas
réfractaire contrairement à ce que
certains pourraient croire ça s'appelle
ça s'appelle le standard triple et ben
vous l’étudierez vous verrez que le
standard triple home Chico répondra à
une de vos questions sur la commande
publique parce que aujourd'hui le
problème de la commande publique comme
de la commande privée d'ailleurs c'est
que les acheteurs sont perdus dans toute
cette foison de norme environnementale
qui existe et effectivement n'importe
quel industriel aujourd'hui peut aller
piocher ce qu'il veut
ce standard triple
ce standard triple merci de
m'interrompre ce standard triple voulait
vous dit tirez la note de cadrage et
vous verrez qu'il répond point par point
ajustement le fléchage vers le 100% vert
merci Madame Chikirou d'avoir posé cette
motion de rejet dernier point si vous
étiez encore avec vous-même puisque vous
ne voulez pas débattre retirez vos
amendements
merci sur le vote de la motion dont j'ai
préalable je suis saisi par le groupe de
la France insoumise d'une demande au
scrutin public qui est annoncée dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale nous
avons donc maintenant des explications
de vote sur cette notion de rejet
préalable deux minutes par intervenant
et par groupe politique le premier pour
le groupe Renaissance la première c'est
Marie le bec
[Applaudissements]
merci merci monsieur le Président alors
que certains d'entre nous préfèrent
hurler au scandale du fond de
l'hémicycle d'autres pérorés sur la
défiscalisation enfin en quelque sorte
jouer les oiseaux de mauvaise augure
nous agissons depuis 2017 nous avons mis
un terme après de 40 ans de désinstru
industrialisation depuis 6 ans nous
avons implanté près de 300 usines et
créer 90 000 emplois industriels ce
texte c'est une brique supplémentaire
car oui nous voulons nous assumons
fièrement nous agissons pour simplifier
les procédures tout en garantissant de
préserver la consultation au public pour
que le foncier est particulièrement les
friches accueillent de nouvelles usines
pour mieux prendre en compte nos
critères environnementaux dans la
commande publique pour orienter
l'épargne du privé vers la décarbonation
de l'industrie nous voulons faire de la
France tout à la fois une nation
productive et à la pointe des enjeux de
demain c'est pourquoi nous votre
rencontre cette notion de rejet merci
monsieur le président
merci pour le groupe rassemblement
national Nicolas maisonnet merci me
merci monsieur le Président alors on a
bien compris que Madame Chikirou et ses
collègues de la princesse soumise
étaient pressés de partir en vacances
sans doute éreinté par leur présence
dans les manifestations anti flics et
celles aux chevet des voyous de ceux qui
pendant plusieurs jours ont mis le feu
au pays et oui on l'a compris on a bien
compris donc qu'il s'agissait pour eux
de faire valoir leurs droits à la
paresse et que dès qu'il fallait faire
des propositions concrètes pour
redresser l'industrie et l'économie de
ce pays il n'y avait il n'y avait plus
personne dès lors qu'il faut parler de
la France du travail dès lors qu'il faut
débattre jouer le jeu de la démocratie
dès lors qu'il faut sortir de la
démagogie une plus raser gratis et bien
il n'y a plus personne du côté de la
française soumise alors nous on
rassemblement national on est conscient
que ce texte est un filet d'eau tiède
s'il vous plaît vaporeux on veut pouvoir
défendre nos propositions défendre la
nécessité d'un grand plan de formation
parler de la vision de l'industrie
nationale que l'on porte créatrice de
richesse et d'emplois pour les Français
il fut un temps il fut un temps cher
collègue lointain ou la gauche
s'occupait encore des ouvriers employés
de l'industrie ce temps est révolu nous
voulons sa collecte pouvoir parler de la
souveraineté nationale de préférence
nationale dans l'attribution des marchés
publics des vertus économiques et
écologiques de la relocalisation nous
voulons pouvoir parler de la nécessité
de rompre avec le libre-échange forcené
que les macronistes vénères nous voulons
pouvoir parler du financement de cette
industrie verte mais pour cela encore
faut-il que la macronie elle-même se
soumettent aux exigences démocratiques
du débat parlementaire encore faut-il
que l'album macronie cesse tout abus de
pouvoir et respecte ses oppositions
encore faut-il que la macronie ne rend
pas nos amendements irrecevables
massivement comme elle vient de le faire
mesdames messieurs de la minorité ité
parlementaire on aurait pu voter contre
cette motion de rejet car nous voulons
se débat mais en raison de cette énième
dérive de votre part je veux que je
viens d'évoquer nous nous absionne merci
Monsieur député pour le groupe et les
filles monsieur Mathias Tavel
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres chers collègues 2 millions
d'emplois détruits dans l'industrie
c'est le bilan de 40 ans de
néolibéralisme on pourrait dire de
macronisme que vous avez encore aggravé
depuis l'élection du président depuis
2017 la production industrielle a baissé
de
4,5%. ça part dans la valeur ajoutée a
encore reculé la part de l'emploi
industriel dans l'emploi total n'a
jamais été aussi basse que depuis que
Monsieur Macron s'occupe de l'économie
du pays c'est-à-dire depuis 9 ans
vous avez continué de porter un coup
majeur contre notre souveraineté contre
l'emploi et contre notre capacité à
affronter le défi écologique face à ça
vous vous payez de mots
industrie verte planification écologique
on se satisfaite cette victoire
sémantique nous qui défendons ses idées
depuis plus de 15 ans avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais comme avec la République
vous prenez les mots pour mieux les
vider de toutes leurs substances car
votre projet de loi est une coquille
vide pas de planification nationale même
pour plaire à Monsieur Bayrou inutile
d'aller chercher jusqu'en Union
soviétique monsieur le Président pas de
stratégie à partir des besoins ni de
sobriété pas de protectionnisme pas de
capital public pas de participation des
salariés grand absents de votre texte
vous nous proposez du macronisme vert
mais dans le macronisme le problème ce
n'est pas la couleur chers collègues
assez perdu de temps
assez perdu de temps si vous voulez
réindustrialiser et bifurquer il faut
rompre avec la logique économique qui
est la vôtre avec la politique de
l'offre avec le productivisme avec le
libre-échange avec la toute puissance
des actionnaires que vous représentez si
bien mais qui défendent si mal l'intérêt
général et l'intérêt national alors si
vous voulez l'Union nationale il faut
rejeter ce texte car l'union nationale
elle ne se fera jamais derrière les
détenteurs du capital qui exploitent la
nature et qui exploite l'homme
merci Monsieur député pour les
républicains Virginie du bimmüller merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteurs
bien que ce texte aborde que
partiellement les enjeux liés à la
réindustrialisation de notre pays nous
ne rejoignons pas du tout la position
des députés et les filles dans leur
critique qui manquent cruellement comme
à l'accoutumé de perspectives et de
compréhension des véritables enjeux
industriels écologiques il serait temps
que EFI adopte une vision plus nuancée
équilibrée de l'industrie et de
l'environnement en s'extirpant des
postures afin de reconnaître
qu'industrialisation et Environnement ne
sont pas antinomiques mais les
partenaires d'une France durable et
prospère l'industrie représente
aujourd'hui 19% des gaz à effet de serre
mais entre 1990 et 2019 l'ensemble des
émissions a baissé de 23% dans ce
secteur d'activité
propositions sont caricaturales et
seraient dangereuses et synonymes de
décroissance et ferait courir le risque
de freiner le développement économique
et technologique de la France et donc
d'impacter négativement les Français
vous portez une vision du monde
manichéenne ou environnement et
industrialisation sont des forces
antagonistes le groupe similaires
s'oppose à cette vision et croit
contrairement à vous au progrès
technologiques et non au déclassement et
à la pauvrissement de la France votre
tendance à présenter les entreprises
comme dans Germinal ou comme un ennemi
incontestable de notre environnement et
caricatural je vous invite d'ailleurs à
venir visiter des entreprises plus
souvent ne vous en déplaît ce n'est
qu'en reconnaissant le rôle crucial de
l'industrialisation que nous pourrons
travailler à bâtir une France à la fois
écologiquement responsable et
économiquement forte nous avons besoin
pour la France et les Français d'une
réindustrialisation massive synonyme
d'un puissant moteur économique et de
progrès technologique et de création
d'emplois le groupe LR s'opposera donc à
la motion de rejet LFI et invite les
députés de votre groupe à voter les
amendements du groupe LR afin de
favoriser la souveraineté industrielle
et la localisation de nos activités
productives afin de prendre en compte
les émissions de carbone importées nous
comptons nous sur des débats pour faire
évoluer positivement contexte et
espérons que ces débats seront plus
apaisés qu'en commission spéciale où
vous avez tout fait pour nourrir et
attiser les tensions merci pour le
groupe démocrates Philippe bolo si
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le Président de la
commission spéciale Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs nous
connaissons tous ici dans cette émission
que les difficultés d'un pays sans usine
ces difficultés nous les avons vécu en
sortie de covid nous les avons vécu lors
du manque de matières premières toujours
en sortie de covid et lors de la
l'apparition de la guerre en Ukraine et
ce sujet là il concerne toutes les
activités la santé l'énergie la mobilité
l'électronique nous sommes donc tous ici
persuadés de la nécessité de regagner en
souveraineté et c'est bien l'objet de ce
texte ensuite nous aurons tous également
l'importance des entreprises sur nos
territoires nous les défendons
d'ailleurs régulièrement lorsqu'elle
rencontre des difficultés nous sommes
tous persuadés de la nécessité de
pérenniser ces entreprises sur tous les
territoires cette pérennité elle passe
par le verdissement et la décarbonation
de notre industrie et c'est aussi
l'objet de ce texte
ensuite dans la communication que nous
avons remise avec ma collègue Virginie
dub Miller dans le cadre du groupe de
suivi sur de la commission des affaires
économiques nous avons pointé les forces
et les faiblesses de ce texte ces
faiblesses si vous voulez les corriger
chers collègues il faut en parler et il
faut débattre du texte c'est la raison
pour laquelle il est absolument
nécessaire de rejeter cette motion de
rejet en débattre c'est améliorer le
texte pour plus de souveraineté pour
plus de décarbonation de notre industrie
c'est le pour le retour de nul industrie
forte de notre pays et pour permettre de
répondre ce qui nous permettra également
de répondre aux transitions que nous
avons à affronter c'est ainsi que le
groupe démocrate appelle à rejeter cette
notion de Roger
merci pour le groupe socialiste Gérard
le seul
[Applaudissements]
merci président monsieur le ministre
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs
l'objectif affiché par le gouvernement
est d'accélérer la réindustrialisation
autour de projets verts et innovants et
de soutenir la décarbonation de
l'industrie mais le texte s'intitule
industrie verte comment faire alors même
que la notion d'industrie verte n'est
toujours pas explicitée que l'ensemble
des amendements de définition et de
précision sur le sujet ont été rejetées
par votre majorité
le texte pourrait être considéré comme
un embryon de réponse au défi industriel
mais il ne permet pas en l'état de
dégager une véritable vision pour une
industrie décarbonée son titre est
trompeur et pourrait justifier de voter
cette notion de rejet préalable de plus
le gouvernement et le camp macroniste
ont procédé un véritable nettoyage du
texte issu du Sénat en supprimant huit
articles notamment les articles premier
bis 1 et 4a relatifs à la stratégie
industrielle nationale et au projet
industrie d'industrie territoriaux les
gains obtenus par les sénateurs
socialistes sont donc aujourd'hui
totalement effacées dès le départ entre
les consultations pilotées au printemps
par la majorité et le dépôt de ce texte
nous exprimons déjà de vivre
interrogations entre son objectif
annoncé d'industrie verte et les
dispositions déclinées pour y parvenir
hier le défaut de compétitivité était dû
aux travailleurs français trop cher trop
protégés une nouvelle légende nous est
aujourd'hui racontée la fuite des
industries serait non pas liée à une
volonté du moindre coût de la part des
distrib mais de la lourde administrative
française il faudrait donc simplifier
tout simplifier besoin foncier avec site
clé en main accélération des procédures
d'urbanisme et des consultations
publiques le gouvernement nous propose
le verdissement de l'industrie avec une
définition contestable et juste un
commencement avorté d'un financement de
l'industrie avec votre PEA qui n'est
même pas populaire formation fiscalité
fabriquée en France participation à la
gouvernance des entreprises
conditionnalités des aides contrôle tout
cela manque au texte gouvernemental qui
pourra aller dans le bon sens mais à
force de renvoyer à des textes
ultérieurs n'a finalement pas grande
ambition
merci pour le groupe horizon Henri
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues nous savons
deux choses la première c'est que nos
modes de production sont responsables du
changement climatique et la deuxième
c'est que nous avons donc très peu de
temps pour agir qu'est-ce que ce projet
de loi propose il propose de favoriser
les industries dont les produits et les
processus de fabrication limite nos
impacts et notre empreintes sur
l'environnement il propose de décarboner
ce qui est une priorité face aux défis
climatiques en faisant comment avec
l'énergie renouvelable que nous avons
passé dans un texte précédent avec le
nucléaire et ça permettrait de sécuriser
les prix et la ressource essentielle à
l'installation de ces industries ce
projet est vertueux car il s'attacha
avant tout au sol déjà artificialisé et
aux friches enfin surtout c'est ne pas
laisser aux autres hors de notre regard
les responsabilités qui nous incombent
et c'est ça la relocalisation des
industries sur notre territoire donc
pour toutes ces raisons le groupe
horizon votre a contre votre motion de
rejet
merci le groupe écologiste Charles
Fournier merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre messieurs mesdames
Messieurs les rapporteurs alors quand
nous nous abordons ce texte les
écologistes nous avons la conviction
profonde et depuis fort longtemps qu'il
y a besoin de réindustrialiser de
transformer notre pays et depuis fort
longtemps nous parler de relocalisation
et d'ailleurs à l'époque on riait de ses
propos aujourd'hui tout le monde semble
être d'accord mais quand nous abordons
ce texte il est abordé comme souvent
dans le désordre la proposition sur la
planification écologique qui se
travaille du côté du cabinet de la de la
première ministre est sans cesse reporté
et ce texte arrive avant aurait été
assez logique qu'il soit enchaîné et
articulé avec cette planification dont
finalement nous attendons aujourd'hui
beaucoup sa sortie quand nous avons ce
texte en commission finalement tous les
amendements qui sont proposés ou presque
sont d'abord considérés comme il
recevable et souvent et souvent pour des
raisons politiques et pas pour des
raisons techniques je vous donne un
exemple un exemple quand nous proposons
un rapport sur les filières industriels
pour voir si elles sont compatibles avec
un scénario 1,5 degrés du GIEC pourquoi
est-ce rejeté c'est totalement lié à
l'enjeu industriel c'est totalement
incompréhensible et je pourrais en citer
des dizaines et des dizaines de cette
nature quand nous débattons en
commission finalement vous dites
beaucoup d'amendements ont été acceptés
mais ils ont sauté avec les articles que
vous avez fait annuler par la suite donc
au final il ne reste pas grand chose
vous avez refusé le débat les
propositions que nous avons apportées
sur ce texte et puis vous avez une
approche de l'industrie que nous verte
que nous ne partageons pas elle n'est
pas définie votre industrie verte ne
tient pas compte des limites planétaires
votre industrie verte fait comme si nous
pouvions produire sans limite vote
industrie verte ignore les salariés ce
que veut dire travailler à l'usine dans
une France à 50 degrés quel nouveau
droit pour les salariés serait possible
votre industrie verte ne dit pas comment
les financements seront conditionnés
d'un point de vue écologique et social
votre industrie verte n'est pas définie
parce qu'elle n'est pas verte alors nous
voterons cette motion de rejet parce que
nous ne sommes pas d'accord à votre
copie et que nous espérions pouvoir
débattre sur une autre copie
merci pour le groupe GDR ubervulfranc
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le groupe communiste est
foncièrement attaché à la
réindustrialisation de notre pays mais
pour cela pour cela un état stratège
doit commander je dis bien commander les
trajectoires de l'appareil productif du
pays pour cela un état stratège doit
réunir les conditions pour que le
capital assure l'essentiel de
l'investissement propre à changer de
système technique pour cela un état
stratège doit former à l'intention de
chaque jeune une trajectoire une
perspective métier qualifiée pour cela
un état stratège doit organiser un
véritable partage de la valeur en faveur
du travail en faveur du salaire pour
cela un état stratège doit savoir
soustraire l'économie nationale au
dumping social initié par la division
internationale du travail
pour cela enfin un état stratège doit
couvrir la priorité industrielle de
l'indispensable
urgence climatique et démocratique votre
texte ne présente à ce stade aucune des
garanties qui en sont tant monsieur le
ministre avait réuni les conditions dans
l'affrontement de une projection
gaulliste et communiste pour que chacun
vive et travaille au pays dans ces
conditions nous demandons à revoir votre
copie nous voterons cette motion de
rejet
merci merci enfin dernier intervenant
pour le groupe lyode Benjamin sainte
suites
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président
je dois dire que le début de semaine
nous laisse à penser que la semaine va
être belle
sur cette motion de rejet préalable le
groupe liotte
ne la votera pas
si la question est de savoir si le titre
peut être trompeur la réponse est sans
doute oui nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir
si la question est de savoir si le texte
est lacunaire la réponse est sans doute
oui mais nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir la question plus large qui est
posée et qui doit être celle au centre
de nos débats c'est la place de
l'industrie dans l'économie française sa
capacité à résister voire à progresser
en termes de points de PIB dans ces
conditions il y a beaucoup de sujets qui
ne sont malheureusement pas abordés dans
ce texte je pense à la question fiscale
je pense cela vient d'être dit à
l'instant à la question de l'emploi mais
il y a aussi la question des procédures
administratives c'est un petit bout de
la lorgnette qui peut nous permettre de
progresser en la matière mais il faut
reconnaître que sur ces sujets il y a de
ça de là quelques éléments
d'amélioration qu'il nous faut pouvoir
aborder ensemble c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous ne voterons pas cette
notion de rejet préalable de manière à
ce que le débat puisse avoir lieu sur le
reste
merci monsieur le député je vais donc
mettre au bout à la boisson de rejet
préalable je vous prie de bien vouloir
regagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
[Musique]
le scrutin est clos
et voici les résultats du scrutin
vos temps en 47 exprimer 129 majorités
65 pour 43 contre 86 l'assemblée n'a pas
adopté nous allons passer à la
discussion générale mais je suspense 5
minutes
la séance est reprise avec la discussion
générale 5 minutes par orateur pour le
groupe Renaissance monsieur Isard
[Applaudissements]
dans le ministre n'est pas encore arrivé
alors il vous coupe dans votre élan
mais il n'est pas très loin
[Musique]
vous pouvez continuer à monter les
marches monsieur
c'est bon monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues la pandémie
mondiale du covid et la guerre en
Ukraine ont ceci de commun qu'elles ont
fait prendre conscience à l'ensemble de
notre pays de la nécessité d'une France
souveraine
souveraine car à l'heure des
bouleversements géopolitiques et
écologiques majeurs notre pays ne peut
plus dépendre des tas tiers pour la
production des biens essentiels au
besoin quotidiens des Français
le projet de loi dont nous entamons
l'examen aujourd'hui participent de la
réponse à cela
je dis participe car il ne s'agit pas
ici d'un texte isolé mais bien de la
nouvelle étape d'une ambitieuse
politique française et européenne
salut on d'abord le rôle joué par France
relance pour accélérer les
transformations écologiques et
industrielles de notre pays en soutenant
notamment la compétitivité de nos
entreprises et la modernisation de notre
industrie
est ensuite venu le plan France 2030 et
ses 10 objectifs visant là encore à
développer notre compétitivité
industrielle à décarboner notre
industrie et à maîtriser les
technologies du futur
et depuis 2017 les premiers résultats
sont là un solde positif d'ouverture
d'usine et 90 000 emplois industriels
créés
c'est une réussite dont nous pouvons
être fiers
mais il nous faut aujourd'hui franchir
encore une étape parce que le
développement industriel clé de notre
souveraineté connaît encore trop
d'obstacles
des obstacles qui pour certains
s'appellent l'Europe pour d'autres le
libre-échange ou que sais-je et qui se
cache derrière des idéologies politiques
bancales et inopérante
pardonnez-nous d'être bien plus
pragmatique
avec ce texte nous mettons au cœur des
débats les véritables obstacles
rencontrés par les industriels qu'il
s'agisse de la question du foncier de
celle des délais d'instruction ou encore
des recours à abusifs
aussi le titre premier de texte nous
permettra d'accélérer concrètement les
délais d'implantation d'usine
aujourd'hui beaucoup trop dissuasifs
pour un porteur de projet
la parallélisation des phases
d'autorisation la réhabilitation des
friches et certains dispositifs
d'introduction introduites en commission
spéciale comme l'encadrement des recours
abusifs nous permettront de réduire par
deux nos délais d'implantation en nous
alignant sur nos voisins européens
mais avec ce texte nous ne ciblons pas
uniquement les nouvelles technologies
vertes cela reviendrait d'une certaine
manière à trahir notre industrie
actuelle et à priver notre pays de ses
richesses
au contraire nous accompagnons chaque
industrie vers son verdissement en
accélérant le récyclage des résidus de
production et en facilitant notamment la
sortie la sortie du statut de déchets
ce verdissement de l'industrie actuelle
est également l'objet du titre 2 qui
actionne le puissant levier de la
commande publique pour inciter à des
pratiques plus vertueuses du point de
vue environnemental et énergétique
enfin le titre 3 fixe les premières
sources de financement avec notamment le
nouveau Plan d'Épargne à venir climat
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui et de demain
savent à quel point la décarbonation de
notre économie est importante à leur
avenir
et avec ce plan nous l'aurons à eux
alors parent la possibilité de s'engager
concrètement dans cette transition en
mettant leur épargne au service de
celle-ci
monsieur le ministre le groupe
Renaissance soutiendra bien évidemment
ce texte parce que non face au défi de
notre temps nous ne nous renfermerons
pas dans nos frontières nationales et
dans une logique du chacun pour soi
parce que non nous ne céderons pas non
plus au mirage de l'écologie
décroissante qui pousse à l'immobilisme
et à la peur de l'innovation
mais parce que oui nous continuerons à
nous appuyer sur une dynamique
européenne exceptionnelle à croire en la
transition par l'innovation et à faire
confiance à nos industriels français qui
chargent qui chaque jour s'engagent
corps et âme pour faire de la France la
nation souveraine et décarbonée que nous
appelons de nos vœux
enfin et pour conclure je tiens à saluer
le travail de toutes les personnes qui
ont œuvré à ce beau projet de loi dont
nous débattrons dans les prochaines
minutes les administrateurs de notre
commission spéciale le conseiller de
groupe Rachel Maxime
ma correspondable de texte la députée
Marie le bec ainsi que l'ensemble des
députés impliqués sur ce texte et bien
sûr leurs collaborateurs merci à tous
pour le groupe rassemblement national
monsieur Alexandre Loubet
[Applaudissements]
merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Industrie ce projet de loi
industrie verte est un aveu un aveu
d'impuissance industrielle
l'industrie n'attend pas de la
technocratie mais bien une stratégie et
une stratégie nationale pourtant ce
gouvernement nous présente un projet de
loi bureaucratique et sans vision qui se
résume à un saupoudrage de mesurettes
insuffisante en réalité ce texte
démontre monsieur le ministre
l'incapacité de votre gouvernement à
rompre avec 40 ans de
désindustrialisation 40 ans qui ont
conduit à délocaliser 2 millions et demi
d'emplois et à rabaisser l'industrie à
9% du PIB national pour retrouver son
indépendance créer de l'emploi à innover
financer son modèle social et ses
retraites ou encore réduire son
empreinte carbone la France doit renouer
avec une puissance nationale et
industrielle
monsieur le ministre ce projet de loi
est un grand gâchis
un grand gâchis car vous vous contentez
de développer une poignée de technologie
verte un grand gâchis car vous ratez
l'occasion de soutenir massivement la
décarbonation de notre industrie
existante et surtout un grand gâchis car
vous ne cherchez pas à relocaliser un
maximum d'activités industrielles sur le
seul français alors même que la moitié
de l'empreinte carbone de la France est
lié à nos importations
monsieur le ministre qui peut
sérieusement croire que votre projet de
loi va réindustrialiser le pays qui peut
y croire alors que ce texte poursuit la
même logique de 40 années de
désindustrialisation en refusant des
bâtir une stratégie nationale
industrielle vous actez votre absence de
vision et d'ambition pour l'industrie
française en refusant de mener une
politique de protectionnisme économique
vous continuez à encourager la
concurrence déloyale et les
délocalisations au détriment des
filières et savoir-faire français en
refusant d'appliquer la priorité
nationale dans la commande publique vous
continuez à subventionner les
importations étrangères avec l'argent du
contribuable en refusant de favoriser
l'emploi français en refusant de nous
libérer du marché européen de l'énergie
vous condamnez la compétitivité de nos
entreprises alors même que la France
produit une des électricités les moins
chères d'Europe en refusant d'accélérer
la relance du nucléaire vous nous
enfoncez dans la sobriété énergétique
que vous émettons et qui rend impossible
la réindustrialisation du pays en
refusant d'alléger certaines normes
environnementales absurdes vous vous
obstinez à laisser les crapauds faire
reculer les pelleteuses et des projets
industriels entiers quitte à sacrifier
des centaines d'emplois on refusant
d'appliquer ces propositions de bon sens
du rassemblement national vous actez la
poursuite de cette désindustrialisation
et du déclin de la France
monsieur le ministre qui peut
sérieusement croire en votre volonté de
réindustrialiser le pays quand vous
continuez de vendre à la découpe nous
ferons stratégiques Alstom Alcatel
technique Lafarge lattecoère souris
industrielles françaises passé sous
pavillon étranger avec l'accord de ce
gouvernement résonne comme les grandes
trahisons industriels des manuels Macron
les grandes trahisons industrielles
d'une élite mondialiste qui bras de le
génie et le travail de son peuple peuple
qui lui est attaché à la puissance
nationale car l'industrie c'est le
moteur de la puissance nationale alors
que nos concurrents comme la Chine et
les États-Unis mènent une diplomatie
économique offensive et un
protectionnisme économique défensif
votre politique industrielle monsieur le
ministre consiste à empêcher de
favoriser les entreprises françaises
alors ajouter toujours plus de
contraintes et à ouvrir toujours plus
dans notre pays aux importations pire
vous confiez une partie de notre
souveraineté économique à une commission
européenne technocratique qui ne défend
ni les intérêts nationaux ni même les
intérêts du continent européen dans son
histoire la France a su rester une
puissance industrielle mondiale en
s'appuyant sur ses ressources sur son
génie sur ses entreprises en s'appuyant
sur un état stratège et une véritable
politique de patriotisme économique en
s'appuyant sur le volontarisme politique
d'homme d'État visionnaire à l'instar de
Colbert ou de Gaulle
le 14 juillet 1960 le général de Gaulle
déclarait justement je cite étant le
peuple français il nous faut accéder aux
rang de grands États industriel où nous
résigner au déclin et bien monsieur le
ministre ce projet de loi démontre que
vous faites le choix vous faites le
choix du déclin au rassemblement
national nous faisons le choix de la
puissance industrielle je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député pour le groupe
LFI Monsieur Laurent Alexandre
[Applaudissements]
chez le Président Mesdames et Messieurs
green washing ouvrez les guillemets
méthode de marketing consistant à
communiquer auprès du public en
utilisant l'argument écologique de
manière trompeuse pour améliorer son
image tel est le projet de loi
industrielle que vous présentez
un texte vide qui passe à côté des
principaux enjeux de notre temps alors
que nos territoires se vident et se sont
vidés de leur industrie avec votre
complicité alors que nous importons des
quatre coins du monde pour compenser
ceux que nous ne produisons plus la
bifurcation écologique ne peut plus être
reportée à demain nous devons redresser
l'industrie du pays tout en optom pour
un modèle de production soutenable nous
préconisons la mise en place d'un
protectionnisme écologique et social et
la planification par les besoins
que de votre que devons-nous produire et
comment députés insoumis et Nuxe nous
sommes des députés proposants demain
nous gouvernerons le pays mais nous
voulons améliorer tout de suite tout ce
qu'il peut l'être écoutez donc nos
propositions pour que cette loi ne reste
pas une occasion manquée votre texte est
une occasion manquée pour engager un
protectionnisme écologique et social
nous proposons le retour de l'État
stratège qui protège nos savoir-faire
nous ne voulons plus de l'État déserteur
celui qui a abandonné la SAM et ses 333
salariés à notre dernier nos fonds de
riz ferment et Renaud produit les mêmes
pièces hors de France nous proposons au
contraire des dispositifs de
relocalisation les productions dans les
secteurs stratégiques pour le pays comme
la santé le transport l'énergie le
textile
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
des produits importés représentent 51%
de l'empreinte carbone des Français nous
proposons de les réduire avec
l'instauration de droits de douane et
d'une taxe kilométrique sur les produits
importés en fonction de critères
écologiques et sociaux
votre texte est une occasion manquée de
planifier les besoins votre vision est
étriquée incohérente voire fumeuse vous
n'avancez ni méthode ni objective vous
imposez au territoire des dispositifs
complexes par le haut sans concertation
fixant plutôt des objectifs structuraux
réduire de moitié nos émissions d'ici 10
ans et la neutralité carbone en 2050
avec une méthode partir des besoins de
la population définie démocratiquement
avec une boussole la règle verte qui
consiste à ne pas prélever sur la nature
davantage que ceux qu'elle peut
reconstituer avec un principe un
aménagement équilibré du territoire par
la priorisation des friches
industrielles délaissées et un grand
plan foncier pour y installer de
nouvelles activités
pour réaliser cette planification
écologique nous nous appuyons sur les
grands oubliés de votre texte les
salariés de l'industrie d'abord qui
connaissent mieux que n'importe qui ici
notre appareil productif nous proposons
de les associer aux objectifs
industriels de la nation et de leur
donner un vrai pouvoir de décision
stratégique dans leur entreprise des
formations adaptées et un droit de
reprise préférentielle lorsqu'une usine
ferme les Oubliés se sont aussi les TPE
et PME pas un mot sur elle avec votre
gouvernement elle peut même un taux
d'impôt sur les sociétés plus élevées
que les grands groupes nous vous
proposons une mesure immédiate rétablir
les tarifs réglementés de l'énergie pour
nos entreprises
c'est urgent pour sauver les 117.000
emplois menacés par la crise de
l'énergie mais non content de manquer
des occasions vous visez parfois
carrément à côté votre dispositif phare
le Plan d'Épargne à venir climat et
largement insuffisant 66 milliards
d'euros annuels sont estimés nécessaires
par le rapport par rapport pisaniferi
pour engager notre transition écologique
lui-même pourtant un temps proche
conseiller du président préconise le
taxer les plus riches pour contribuer à
la financer mais vous écartez cette
option vous subventionnez au contraire
ceux qui polluent en supprimant l'ISF ou
un supplément des impôts et cotisations
sans fixer de contrepartie
environnementale et sociales nous
proposons un impôt écologique sur la
fortune pour les patrimoines les plus
polluants le prix de la bifurcation ne
peut pas reposer toujours sur les mêmes
écologie doit rimer avec justice fiscale
et sociale et non avec exclusion des
plus pauvres et cadeaux fiscaux pour les
plus riches vous visez à côté encore
dans la réduction des délais
d'implantation de site industriel
Emmanuel Macron demande une pause
réglementaire à matière de normes
environnementale je vous suggère au
contraire de faire une pause
réglementaire dans les dispositifs
dérogatoires vous détricotez le droit de
l'environnement et la participation du
public pour au final tout complexifier
je finis nous avons finalement trouvé
votre définition de l'industrie verte
une usine à biogaz administrative nous
vous proposons plus simple donner aux
services de l'État et des collectivités
territoriales les moyens de mieux à
construire les dossiers
[Applaudissements]
merci pour le groupe des Républicains
madame Virginie dubismillaire
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues nous
examinons aujourd'hui le projet de loin
industrie verte qui a pour objectif de
favoriser la réindustrialisation des
carbonées de la France pour atteindre
cette ambition il se concentre sur trois
exigences principales faciliter
favoriser et financer pour faciliter
l'implantation et le développement de
sites industriels notamment les
gigafactory le projet de loi prévoit
d'accélérer les délais d'implantation de
structurer une filière de recyclage et
de simplifier les procédures
d'autorisation environnementale il
propose également des mesures pour
favoriser l'utilisation des matières
premières recyclées dans l'industrie et
pour sanctionner les exportations
illicites de déchets quant au
financement de l'industrie verte il se
fera grâce à l'épargne privée enfin pour
favoriser les entreprises vertueuses le
projet de loi propose de privilégier une
commande publique responsable en prenant
en compte des critères environnementaux
lors du choix des fournisseurs ils
prévoient également des mesures pour
encourager la réhabilitation de friches
industrielles pour faciliter la
consultation du public lors des projets
industriels ce texte est donc un texte
qui se veut ambitieux et co-construit il
a en effet été préparé en concertation
avec des parlementaires des élus locaux
et des chefs d'entreprise dans le cadre
de groupe de travail thématiques à
l'Assemblée nationale le travail du
groupe de suivi que j'ai qu'au présidée
avec Philippe Bolot a permis de mettre
en exergue des leviers d'action
insuffisamment traités dans le projet de
loi d'ailleurs malgré l'ambition un
fichier par le gouvernement les
différents rapporteurs du Sénat ont
regretté qu'ils soient composés
principalement de mesures techniques
ainsi que l'absence de moyens financiers
renvoyés par le gouvernement à la loi de
finance pour 2024 amputant le texte d'un
volet essentiel l'examen du projet de
loi à l'Assemblée nationale en
commission spéciale à certes permis de
l'enrichir sur divers aspects liés à la
gestion des déchets à la commande
publique à la transition écologique ou à
l'investissement responsable mais nous
restons encore loin des objectifs
affichés par le gouvernement
certaines questions essentielles restent
en suspens comme le problème du coût du
travail qui reste en France l'un des
plus élevés d'Europe où notre capacité à
fournir aux industriels une énergie
abordable problème structurels et
prioritaires du secteur or c'est notre
souveraineté économique qui est
aujourd'hui en jeu les freins que
rencontrent les industriels sont
désormais clairement identifiés comme
l'avait souligné d'ailleurs le rapport
de Laurent Guillot ancien dirigeant
général adjoint de Saint-Gobain intitulé
simplifié et accélérer les implantations
d'activité économiques en France je cite
les entreprises se heurtent à deux
écueils les délaisses des procédures
administratives et le foncier
immédiatement disponible qui va se
raréfier avec l'objectif du Zéro
artificialisation nette une année
d'attente est un délai bien trop long
pour un industriel son marché peut
changer durant ce laps de temps sa
capacité financière se réduire ses
concurrents prendre une avancée décisive
alors qu'il faut 17 à 19 mois pour
implanter une usine en France seulement
4 à 12 mois sont nécessaires en
Allemagne et si sa 13 mois en Suède le
premier volet du projet de loi veut donc
réduire de moitié les délais
d'autorisation pour l'implantation des
sites industriels pour passer de 17 à 19
mois parce qu'il est impératif de
raccourcir ses délai bien trop longs qui
freine la compétitivité française nous
porterons plusieurs amendements visant à
protéger les demandes d'installation
industrielles de l'inflation normative
qui retarde l'installation des projets
et des courages des implantations
industrielles en France quand on second
volet du projet de loi il prévoit la
réhabilitation de friches industrielles
et la mise à disposition de terrain pour
l'industrie via un investissement de 1
milliard d'euros de la banque des
territoires s'il s'agit d'une idée
louable tous les territoires ne
disposent pas de friches industrielles
sans compter que pour se développer les
projets industriels doivent surtout être
excluses là encore nous porterons des
amendements à ce sujet le troisième
volet est donc dédié au financement le
gouvernement propose de créer le livret
d'épargne climat pour les mineurs mais
il s'agit en réalité d'une refonte du
Livret de Développement Durable le
gouvernement souhaite également
développer le capital investissement
dans l'assurance-vie et le plan épargne
retraite et orienter l'épargne privée
vers des fonds labellisés par l'État il
prévoit également un renforcement du
soutien au PME et aux ETI industriels
notamment par le biais de Fonds Européen
d'Investissement long terme toutefois en
ce qui concerne la mise en place du
crédit d'impôt pour les investissements
dans les cas de secteurs définis comme
verre par le gouvernement batterie
éolien solaire et pompe à chaleur le
choix des industries retenu reste limité
alors que la crise du covid a montré
l'importance de notre souveraineté
alimentaire et médicale alors que notre
balance commerciale attend un déficit
record 174 milliards en 2022 on peut se
demander pourquoi l'industrie médicale
l'industrie lourde ou l'industrie
agroalimentaire et tant d'autres ne
bénéficie pas elle aussi de dispositifs
de soutien de l'État dans ce projet de
loi aussi Monsieur le Ministre ce texte
va dans le bon sens car nous partageons
vos ambitions de réindustrialisation et
de sobriété mais il est essentiel
d'aller plus loin
en incitant plus largement la
relocalisation des activités productives
en France afin de rétablir notre
souveraineté industrielle en promouvant
l'emploi et la création de valeur mais
aussi en réduisant nos émissions de
carbone les députés républicains sont
pleinement investis et nous espérons que
nos propositions seront entendues
conditions pour que nous apportions
notre soutien à ce texte merci
pour le groupe démocrate Monsieur
Frédéric zinski
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
chers collègues il faut que tout change
pour que rien ne change cette phrase
résonne en nous à l'heure où les
tensions n'ont jamais été aussi fortes
entre notre aspiration à l'émancipation
et son inscription dans les limites
écologiques
en d'autres termes c'est notre sécurité
sociale et notre sécurité
environnementale que l'on ne cesse
d'opposer
pourtant nous avons le devoir de
réinventer l'idée de progrès social non
pas sur le siècle socle de l'abondance
matérielle comme cela était le cas dans
le passé mais à partir d'un nouveau
partenariat avec la terre et le
territoire via les médiations techniques
et industrielles
pour cela créer un nouveau pacte est
nécessaire
ce texte en prend la direction pour
réunir culture industrielle et culture
écologique la stratégie est claire tout
d'abord décarboner les industries
existantes qui représentent 18% des
émissions de CO2
ensuite accélérer l'implantation et la
réimplantation de technologie
industrielle celle qui nous permettront
de créer des filières complètes
souveraines propres et créatrice de
valeur
produire propre et en France tel est
notre objectif commun
ce texte intervient alors comme une
boîte à outils au service de cet
objectif tout d'abord pour libérer du
foncier nos industriels doivent avoir
les terrains nécessaires à
l'implantation de leurs projets pour
accélérer nos procédures ensuite
celles-ci sont quasiment deux fois plus
longs que chez nos voisins allemands
avec ce projet nous souhaitons diviser
par deux les délais d'ouverture et
d'agrandissement d'une usine en France
et passer de 17 à 9 mois réels nous
passerons pour cela d'une procédure
successive à une procédure parallèle
au lieu de déposer un dossier d'attendre
la vie de l'autorité environnementale
pour ensuite réaliser une enquête
publique recevoir le rapport du
commissaire enquêteur et enfin passer à
la rédaction de l'arrêté d'autorisation
toutes ces phases se feront en même
temps permettant un gain considérable
mais aussi une avancée pour les
consultations publiques qui pourront
désormais se tenir pendant trois mois et
pas seulement pendant un mois
l'état pourra également prendre la main
pour accélérer les procédures de
certains projets d'intérêt national
majeur évalué à la lumière de leur
impact sur l'emploi sur l'environnement
et sur notre souveraineté nationale il
ne s'agit pas d'accélérer les projets
allant contre le sens de l'histoire mais
de permettre aux investisseurs de
projets vertueux de se projeter en
France plus facilement
pour accélérer cette transition profonde
la commande publique est un levier
essentiel à activer nous saluons ainsi
la création d'un motif d'exclusion des
marchés publics pour les entreprises
n'ayant pas réalisé leur bilan
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
alors qu'elles y étaient contraintes
mais pour ne laisser personne sans
solution le groupe démocrate proposera
au gouvernement de réfléchir à une
nouvelle méthode permettant d'établir le
BGS plus accessible pour les entreprises
ou bien de mettre en avant des méthodes
simplifiées déjà existantes
l'investissement du groupe démocrate sur
ce projet est totale en témoins de celui
du président de la commission spéciale
Bruno milliennes et de notre rapporteur
Anne Laure Babeau dont nous saluons le
travail et l'engagement nous tenons
aussi à saluer l'engagement des autres
commissaires de mon groupe de notre
groupe Philippe bolo Mohamed lakila et
Delphin lingeman nous avons été forces
de proposition en commission pour
simplifier nos procédures tout en
préservant nos exigences
environnementales et nous serons
également au rendez-vous cette semaine
soucieux et responsable de l'impact des
activités industrielles nous saluons
l'adoption en commission de notre
amendement visant à interdire
l'exportation de vêtements de seconde
main qui seraient considérés comme
déchets une fois arrivé dans le pays
destinataire enfin le nouveau comité de
financement de la transition écologique
a évalué le besoin à 60 à 70 milliards
d'euros par an pour financer la
transition écologique la mobilisation de
l'épargne privée constitue donc une
partie de la solution et la création
d'un plan épargne à venir climat
également la nature plus complexe de ce
produit nécessitera un vrai travail de
promotion et d'accompagnement auprès des
épargnants pour garantir son succès
par ailleurs plusieurs mesures vissent à
accélérer le développement du capital
investissement dans l'assurance vie et
les plans épargne retraite
l'investissement dans les actifs non
cotés présente la belle opportunité de
résoudre une équation difficile financer
la transition écologique et l'économie
réelle en participant au développement
des PME et des ETI néanmoins
responsabilité le devoir de conseil a
été raffermi grâce notamment au travail
des sénateurs fac une classe d'actifs
jugée plus risquée il est essentiel que
le client est à sa disposition la
formation la plus étendue possible ce
qui est un gage de sa protection pour
conclure le groupe démocrate soutiendra
donc fermement ce texte rappelons que
d'après les estimations de RTE se sont
900 millions de tonnes de CO2 d'ici 2050
que nous pourrions éviter grâce à une
réindustrialisation massive nous n'avons
donc pas le choix réinventer le progrès
social et économique par l'écologie
telle doit être notre défi commercial je
vous remercie le député
pour le groupe socialiste monsieur
Gérard le seul
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur sur le président de la
commission spéciale chers collègues vous
avez avec le camp présidentiel
lourdement communiqué dès le printemps
sur la préparation de ce projet de loi
ainsi 12 pilotes six députés de la
majorité amer 5 chefs d'entreprise ont
été chargés de 5 chantiers thématiques
plus de 300 auditions 138 contributions
écrites 27 propositions sans aucune
concertation avec l'opposition
à l'arrivée à l'arrivée des questions
liées à la formation au financement de
la décarbonation des industries et aux
aides en faveur de nos constructeurs
automobiles nationaux initialement
présentés en conseil des ministres ont
toutes disparu
tout cela pour ça pourrions nous dire de
même le chantier relatif à la fiscalité
ne connaît aucune traduction dans votre
projet de loi vous restez accroché à une
vision libérale d'allègement des
contributions alors qu'il faudrait
notamment
urgemment fléchés le crédit d'impôt
recherche sur des TPEPME et le
conditionner le récent rapport du Sénat
sur la pénurie de médicaments présidé
par Sonia de la pauvreté rapporté par
Laurence Cohen ne dit pas autre chose et
permet de mettre en lumière des
pratiques du CR hautement contestables
bien sûr nous souhaitons tous maintenir
et développer nos emplois actuels dans
l'industrie on verdir ces modes de
production réindustrialiser nos
territoires en développant une
souveraineté industrielle dans de
nombreux secteurs nous l'avons écrit à
de très nombreuses reprises mais votre
texte ne porte pas de réel ambition
nationale mobilisatrice d'efforts
collectifs pour une industrie que nous
pourrions qualifier de vertes
vous ne faites pas de clair distinction
entre industrie verte et verdissement de
l'industrie vous entretenez la confusion
y compris dans vos propos introductifs
nous proposerons donc de définir la
notion d'industrie verte qui doit
s'inscrire dans une logique de
décarbonation des activités mais
également de production de biens utiles
dans le cadre de la transition
écologique et en limitant la pression
sur les ressources au biodiversité et
matériaux
s'agissant des mesures en matière
d'urbanisme et d'aménagement le projet
de loi étant et renforce le disposition
relative au projet logistique au projet
industriel dans les stradettes il ne
prévoit cependant aucune procédure de
modification de révision même simplifiée
pour actualiser ses documents en
conséquence ce qui vu lors durée de vie
de 10 à 15 ans apparaît problématique en
outre aucun objectif national ou
territorialisé n'est avancé dans votre
texte il apparaît également
indispensable où il apparaîtrait
indispensable de réintégrer l'article
premier a sur la stratégie industrielle
obtenue par les sénateurs socialistes et
supprimés en commission spéciale
le développement notamment les notions
de formation de gouvernance des
entreprises et d'orientation des aides
publiques sans stratégie et sans
construction avec et pour nos
territoires comment comptez-vous
protéger et orienter notre industrie et
notre outil industriel territorial en ce
sens nous sommes également inquiets de
la suppression de l'article 4a sur les
projets industriels territoriaux qui
permettraient pourtant d'aborder le
sujet de l'économie circulaire en se
basant sur la notion d'écologie
industrielle territoriale développée par
l'ADEME pour faire en sorte qu'au moment
de leur installation les entreprises
soient incitèrent à réfléchir à leur
intégration dans un écosystème favorable
en fonction de leurs besoins partage
d'énergie réutilisation de matériaux ou
de certains procédés changent de
procédés frais etc
nous alertons également sur la grande
confusion entre tenue à l'article 7
entre les sujets de renaturation de
restauration et de compensation vous
mélangez des concepts extrêmement
différents au détriment de la
biodiversité qui réclament plus que
jamais des actions d'envergure pour
préserver nos écosystèmes clés la
marchandisation de la nature par
l'intermédiaire de titre de compensation
qui pourront par ailleurs être utilisés
comme des crédits carbone est un grave
recul pour la préservation de
l'environnement il faut au contraire
réaffirmer la séquence ERC votée en 2016
dans le cadre de la loi pour la
reconquête de la biodiversité et
instauré des sites de compensation de
haute qualité dont l'agrément serait
conditionnée par des avis conformes du
Comité national de la biodiversité et de
l'Office français de la biodiversité
nous vous invitons à prendre ce sujet
très au sérieux monsieur le rapporteur
général monsieur le Président de la
caution enfin les mesures en matière de
commande publique qui consiste à exclure
les soumissionnaires ne respectant pas
leur obligation de reporting au titre de
la CSRD ou des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre sont bienvenus métro limitées
trop limité dans leur portée il s'agira
d'interroger d'ailleurs à ce sujet le
gouvernement sur la mise en œuvre des
mesures votées dans la loi énergie
renouvelable
le chantier du financement de
l'industrie verte connaît les mêmes
limites on renvoie la création d'alabel
industrie verte 3e à la création d'un
plan épargne climat jeune placé en actif
productif ou encore le financement des
entreprises nos côtés engagées dans la
transition grâce à l'épargne retraite et
d'assurance vie tout cela n'a pas grand
chose d'une mobilisation d'épargne
populaire en conclusion il manque une
vision globale pour la transition
énergétique du secteur et le
développement de champion industriel
rien sur le soutien aux filières par
exemple ou sur la consommation d'énergie
des industriels de nombreuses
dispositions attendues sont manquantes
en matière de financement et de
fiscalité quelle disposition du rapport
du groupe de pilotage intégré au projet
de loi de finance 2024 en conclusion
donc nous sommes très en attente de la
présence de nos amendements pour pouvoir
discuter de ce texte je vous remercie
merci pour le groupe horizon monsieur
Vincent Thiébaut
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
monsieur le Président de la commission
spéciale mes chers collègues notre
nouvelle économie plus verte plus
respectueuse de terre et de nos paysages
n'est pas un rêve mais une réalité qui
nous permet de créer des emplois et de
tenir nos engagements pour le climat
voici mes chers collègues les mots que
prononcés le président de la République
Emmanuel Macron en avril dernier avant
tout je vais ici vous le dire car au
sein du groupe horizon nous en sommes
convaincus non une économie plus verte
plus responsable n'est pas un rêve un
verset un demi-siècle de
désintérialisation en France n'est pas
un rêve faire de notre pays une France
plus souveraine industriellement
économiquement écologiquement n'est pas
un rêve ce texte de loi nous permettra
d'aller plus loin de poursuivre nos
efforts engagés depuis 2017 de donner
les moyens industries non seulement de
se verdir mais aussi de se redéployer
partout sur nos territoires
ce test inscrit doit continuer de ces
cinq dernières années où nous avons
œuvré pour que les 2,5 millions
d'emplois détruits par rien duralisation
des intuitions pardon pour que les
milieux d'usine fermés depuis maintenant
50 ans et que la paire de souveraineté
industrielle ne soit plus une fatalité
nous avons réussi à verser la tendance
cela a été dit avec plus de 300
ouvertures d'usines 90 000 emplois
industriels créés depuis 2017 une
augmentation du nombre par deux des
apprentis en France notamment dans la
filière industrielle pour en faire une
filiale d'excellence
issue du consultation de plusieurs mois
ce projet de loi en temps répondre à nos
ambitions non seulement en matière de
souveraineté mais également en matière
de transition écologique accompagner la
localisation de notre tissu industriel
encourager la création d'emploi dans ce
secteur tout à l'accompagnant notre
appareil productif dans la réduction de
son impact climatique global notre
ambition mes chers collègues c'est de
faire de notre pays un des leaders dans
les technologies vertes en Europe c'est
précisément c'est précisément ce projet
de loi qui devra nous permettre de faire
de nos ambitions des réalités concrètes
à travers différentes mesures telles que
le développement industriel organisé à
travers une planification
à l'échelle régionale des procédures
administratives accélérées notamment
pour les autorisations et des grands et
permis sans à moins dire les obligations
et les ambitions environnementales
lutter contre la gestion illégale des
déchets qui doit être sévèrement puni
nous avons ouvrés notamment dans ce sens
lors de la commission spatiale avec le
groupe horizon
la réhabilitation des friches en vue
d'un usage industriel facilité pour
respecter nos objectifs de
non-respectations des sols soutenir les
productions les plus vertueuses à
travers la commande publique par la
prise en compte considération
environnementale mobilisée davantage de
financement notamment par les pannes
privées afin de répondre aux besoins de
développement des filières d'avenir ces
mesures viennent compléter des textes
précédemment que ce soit la loi
anti-gaspillage économie circulaire pour
une consommation plus dure plus
responsable la loi climat est résilience
ou la loi serait impactent
environnementaux numériques qui favorise
notamment la prise en compte de
l'économception ou les filières de les
filières et l'usage du matériel de
reconditionné notamment de la commande
publique vous l'aurez compris mes chers
collègues ce texte est un texte majeur
aux objectifs clairs facilité favoriser
et financer une industrie plus
souveraine plus verte et plus décarbonée
après des décennies de désintrus
désintustrialisation pardon et de perte
de savoir-faire nous devons redonner
notre pays les moyens de une industrie
compétitive et responsable et créatrice
d'emploi une industrie verte décarbonée
et notre meilleure espoir pour un avenir
durable et poster ensemble nous pouvons
le faire la différence ensemble nous
pouvons construire un monde où
l'Industrie de l'Environnement quoi
existe harmonieusement engageons-nous
dès aujourd'hui à soutenir à promouvoir
l'industrie verte des carbonée le temps
presse est notre planète compte sur nous
au nom du groupe horizon apparenté je
tiens saluer le travail l'engagement des
rapporteurs sur ce texte en particulier
c'est celle de notre collègue
Marie-Agnès poussiéback et je tiens
également à remercier ensemble nos
collègues du rapporteur général et
l'ensemble des rapporteurs et du
ministre pour le travail effectué en
commission spéciale vous l'aurez bien
entendu nous soutiendrons ce texte et
nous œuvrons en tout cas pour l'enrichir
merci à vous
merci monsieur le député pour le groupe
écologiste Monsieur Charles Fournier
merci sur le président messieurs
monsieur le ministre mes Messieurs et
Mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs nous
sommes sur l'autoroute de l'enfer
climatique avec le pied toujours sur
l'accélérateur sont des mots d'Antonio
guteres à la Coop 27 et aujourd'hui
évidemment on nous dit qu'il faut
accélérer accélérer les procédures
accélérer notre industrialisation
accélérer notre souveraineté accélérer
notre retour dans la compétition
internationale en vérité ce qui
s'accélère aujourd'hui très fortement
c'est le dérèglement climatique c'est le
dépassement des limites planétaires 6
sur 9 aujourd'hui sont dépassés c'est
notre prospérité qui est en cause le
projet de loi dit d'industrie verte et
finalement et j'ai lu ça quelque part
plutôt un projet qui s'occupe du climat
des affaires que réellement du climat
c'est un texte qui vise à rassurer des
investisseurs en leur disant venez en
France il y aura du foncier disponible
venez en France il y aura des moyens qui
vont descendre et couler à flots verts
des projets de réindustrialisation
venait en France on va desserrer le code
de l'environnement et vous pourrez
investir dans notre dans notre pays
pourtant pour les écologistes cette
question de la réindustrialisation elle
est majeure mais elle n'est pas qu'une
affaire de décarbonation mot qui
remplace tous les autres elle n'est pas
qu'une affaire de souveraineté et ce
texte d'ailleurs ne va pas au bout sur
ce sujet là une industrie réellement
verte c'est une industrie qui prend en
considération toutes les limites
planétaires c'est une industrie qui se
préoccupe des sols de l'air c'est une
industrie qui se préoccupe de l'eau qui
se préoccupe des pollutions qui se
préoccupent de la santé globale la santé
du vivant des humains comme des non
humains qui se préoccupent de la qualité
de vie dans nos territoires et tout ça
n'est pas dans votre texte vous parliez
tout à l'heure de ceux qui connaîtraient
les entreprises et ceux qui ne les
connaîtraient pas j'ai eu l'occasion de
préparer ce texte de faire de nombreuses
visites dans des entreprises de
rencontrer des chefs d'entreprises de
rencontrer des salariés de rencontrer
des sous-traitants de rencontrer des
artisans des PME PMI qui ne se sentent
d'ailleurs pas très concernés par votre
texte
alors oui évidemment nous avons des
situations comme acroll vous nous avez
conseillé d'y aller nous y avons été
nous avons beaucoup discuté une
entreprise qui demain
consomme pardon aujourd'hui 4,5 millions
de mètres cubes d'eau potable en 2022 ce
qui représente 20 % de la suspendie par
la métropole de Grenoble alors demain
ils vont faire des progrès ils
consomeront autant pour produire plus
mais ils ne sont pas tous seuls dans le
territoire d'autres consomment aussi et
nous aurons un problème de partage de
l'eau une industrie verte se préoccupe
de ces enjeux nous avons été visité
l'entreprise Arkema à côté de de Lyon et
vous savez la pollution avec l'épiface
nous vous avons interrogé à plusieurs
reprises on nous avait dit qu'un député
avait été nommé pour traiter le sujet
voulez-vous accélérer dans les réponses
nécessaires là-dessus voulez-vous
interdire immédiatement la présence et
la famille des pifas dans les
parlons dans les emballages alimentaires
et dans tous nos tissus ça c'est aussi
une accélération tout à fait attendue
l'industrie c'est aussi des pollutions à
contrôler c'est aussi le manque d'eau
qui est en jeu c'est aussi les enjeux
énergie alors nous pouvons relocaliser
mais pas un apport quelles conditions le
modèle de la gigafactory nous ne le
rejetons pas par principe mais nous
estimons qu'il y a des alternatives et
qu'il faut les étudier il y a la
possibilité d'une égalité des
territoires de penser des
micro-entreprises de pensées le tissu
des PME PMI et de tout notre artisanat
industriel qui se sont largement oubliés
dans votre texte il y a possibilité de
produire autrement et de répondre à nos
besoins en nous limitant à nos besoins
parce que nous ne pouvons pas produire
sans limite pour faire tout ça il nous
faut une industrie qui premièrement
prend la conscience de ses limites
planétaires nouveau proposons par
exemple de mettre en place dans les
territoires des conseils de sobriété
comme c'est le cas dans mon territoire
c'est initié pour traiter de la question
de l'eau pour traiter de la question de
l'énergie pour traiter de la question
des matières premières nous vous
proposons une industrie des besoins
avant nos besoins de la face fashion
avons-nous besoin du Quick commerce la
réponse est non comment allons-nous
sortir de ces activités prédatrices de
notre avenir nous avons besoin d'une
planification descendante mais aussi
ascendante comment associer des
territoires où est la démocratie comment
faire avec les riverains comment faire
avec toutes les parties prenantes de
l'entreprise les sous-traitants les
fournisseurs etc etc nous vous proposons
des conventions citoyennes
territorialisées pour penser cette
réindustrialisation il faut repenser nos
outils de production nos manières de
produire avec l'école l'économie
circulaire l'écologie industrielle
l'innovation lothèque il y a plein de
voix vous ne vous en êtes pas saisi nous
les avions proposés par amendement une
consommation qui se transforme nous
devons sortir de l'obsolescence
programmée nous devons aller vers les
colonies de la fonctionnalité nous
devons prendre en considération les
externalités négatives il faut aller
plus vite là-dessus il nous faut une
industrie du collectif de la coopération
et de la modernité sociale nous vous
proposons par exemple d'inscrire dans le
rôle des CSE l'élaboration des
stratégies de transition des entreprises
et le droit de regard sur les
financements publics attribués aux
entreprises et enfin nous vous proposons
une industrie soutenue par des
financements publics transparents
efficaces écologiquement et socialement
allez-vous nous dire quels sont les
contreparties des 2,9 milliards accordés
à stmicroélectronique et globalfriends
pour le site de Grenoble allez-vous nous
dire quels sont clairement ces
contreparties ces sacs nous attendons
alors nous disons mille fois oui à la
réindustrialisation mais autrement le
temps du produit optimisme révolue le
temps d'une industrie résiliente doit
advenir
merci monsieur le député pour le groupe
GDR Sébastien Jumel
président ministre rapporteur collègue
bon les cocos premier message on veut
pas de leçon les entreprises les cocos
veulent pas de son
ils entreprises on les connaît pas
besoin d'aller les visiter on vit avec
elles sont sur nos territoires les
organisations syndicales les salariés
on est à leur côté depuis toujours
progrès d'ailleurs que vous n'ayez pas
pris soin de vous nourrir de leur
expertise pour ce texte et puis on n'a
pas attendu 2023 pour produire français
il y avait des affiches dans les années
70 là où vous l'amigniez l'industrie ou
sur les murs de notre pays nous
indiquions la nécessité de recouvrer la
souveraineté made in France parce que
les deux millions de cent mille emplois
perdus ils ne sont pas perdus par
opération du Saint-Esprit c'est le fruit
de renoncement successifs dont les
libéraux que vous êtes sont la
continuation les traités libre-échange
OMC traités européens traité de
libre-échange qui ont fait en sorte que
la concurrence soit libre et au nom
fossé qu'elle se fasse au détriment de
notre tissu industriel Florange ou
Whirlpool ascoval Arcelor péchiné ou la
liquidation d'Alcatel il y a des
responsables
les politiques qu'on laissait faire et
les patrons qui ont été complices de
cela les mêmes patrons d'ailleurs qui
arboraient des fois des badges en disant
avec les aides on va créer un million
d'emplois j'ai sorti un schéma monsieur
le ministre des aides à louer aux
entreprises entre 79 et 2019 pour les
aides aux entreprises on est passé de 9
milliards 7 à 156 milliards 88 pour les
exonérations en toutes sortes de
dépenses socio fiscales de dépenses
fiscale de dépenses budgétaire le schéma
suive la même courbe et malheureusement
les saignées industriels avec les drames
humains qui vont avec ont continué à
laminer nos territoires et les habitants
qui vont avec tout cela par idéologie
tout ça parce que cette chair est basée
par là et tout cela parce que vous avez
affaibli l'état toujours avec les mêmes
solutions les autosules totaux et les
exonérations en vocations à produire des
effets alors Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui déclare son amour en
industrie on devrait l'appeler Emmanuel
Montebourg on devrait appeler d'ailleurs
le ministre de l'Économie Bruno De
Gaulle à l'entendre il a réinventé son
amour pour l'industrie mais derrière les
déclarations d'amour derrière les
paroles il faut passer aux actes un pas
que vous peinez à franchir d'abord vous
saucissonnez grandement la politique
industrielle ENR accélération du
nucléaire
baisse des impôts de production nous
avait fait un choix politique et puis
vous renvoyer à la loi de finances tout
un tas de sujets stratégiques qui
auraient dû être au cœur de cette loi
mais le pire est ailleurs vous oubliez
par exemple qu'avec les impôts on peut
financer uberville-france en fera la
démonstration dans sa commission
d'enquête des infrastructures
ferroviaires nécessaires pour la relance
industrielle du service public efficace
que les entreprises vous demandent
lorsqu'elles font le choix de
s'implanter sur un territoire et bref
vous faites un choix idéologique
consérant que les impôts sont un
obstacle à l'implantation de l'Indus
alors que c'est l'inverse et puis votre
texte brille par son absence à rien sur
la formation qui est absente rien sur
l'organisation des filières inconnue au
bataillon rien sur la relance de la
recherche et développement au service de
développement industriel toutes ces
manques ne sont pas accessoires ils sont
révélateurs d'une approche des cabinets
feutrés sans combat sur les territoires
les moyens et les bras soient mobilisés
plus encore forcée de constater que ce
texte permettra pas non plus de réaliser
la transition écologique de l'industrie
en effet ce texte rate l'essentiel il ne
faut pas de notre point de vue une
industrie verte il faut considérer que
l'industrie est verte quand elle est
relocalisée il faut verdir l'ensemble
des pans de notre industrie c'est-à-dire
investir massivement dans la
décarbonation c'est à dire conditionner
les aides des entreprises et la commande
publique à cet objectif de transition
écologique c'est-à-dire responsabiliser
les grands groupes envers leur
sous-traitants le texte est
et même muet sur ces sujets là comment
comment considérer qu'on peut atteindre
une souveraineté industrielle verte
quand 40% des entrants industriels sont
extraits à l'étranger dans des
conditions souvent déplorables au plan
écologique et au plan social sans
régulation du marché sans
protectionnisme intelligent sans au
niveau de formation sans investissement
massif pas d'industrie vert possible je
veux terminer par la proclamation du
ministre qui est allé chercher le
général de Gaulle
pour étayer son texte mais sous de
Gaulle on avait un EDF fort qui nous
permettait d'avoir des tarifs
réglementés au service de la
souveraineté industrielle sous de Gaulle
on avait une SNCF unifiée qui nous
permettait de mailler le territoire y
compris en matière de frais de
ferroviaire sous de Gaulle il y avait un
pacte social fiscal avec des salariés
sous statut qui nous permettaient
d'envisager merci
quelles sont les grands absents de
l'État stratège qui manque dans votre
politique voilà mes collègues
pour le groupe pilote monsieur Benjamin
sainte huile
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteurs monsieur le Président de la
commission spéciale parce que nous
aimons l'industrie parce qu'elle a
façonné nos territoires nous sommes
évidemment attentifs et attachés à la
question de la réindustrialisation on
nous réjouissant que nous posions ce
sujet sur la table je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure la part de l'industrie dans le
PIB est stable aujourd'hui à 11% à après
s'être effondré chacun la relevée la
question qui est posée aujourd'hui c'est
de savoir si ce texte il peut permettre
à l'industrie française de retrouver sa
force et sa place si nous allons passer
du temps sur cette question il faut
relever que d'autres leviers doivent
être activés le loyer fiscal vous l'avez
fait souvent à travers les impôts de
production et je veux dire ici
aujourd'hui que si nous nous concéderons
pas cette question comme tabou nous
considérons par contre qu'il faut mettre
fin au saupoudrage et que plutôt que de
choisir la CVAE il faudrait peut-être
aujourd'hui s'intéresser à la CFE
choisir le ciblage parce que si on veut
aider l'industrie c'est plutôt sur cette
question qu'on sera en situation de
faire des propositions effectives
parler fiscalité parler aussi emploi les
uns et les autres l'ont dit ici
l'attractivité des filières le
changement d'image des métiers la
capacité à mieux orienter nos jeunes et
finalement à donner des perspectives
d'avenir avec des parcours de réussite
et puis le dernier élément sur la
question industrielle c'est sans doute
la question de procédure administrative
celle que vous traitez finalement
largement dans ce texte sans prendre le
temps de traiter les deux premiers pans
que je viens d'évoquer alors réduction
de délai d'instructions très bien divisé
par deux pour être à peu près au niveau
de nos concurrents européens ça va
plutôt dans le bon sens avec une petite
attention sur la place c'est le rôle des
collectivités territoriales qui est
toujours atténuée attention à la
question de la concertation publique qui
si elle était malmenée nous emmènerait
de manière irrémédiable vers plus de
contentieux et moins d'acceptabilité et
quand on va vers le contentieux on va
aussi vers des des temps qui s'allongent
et que nous ne maîtrisons pas forcément
libération du foncier pour avoir des
sites dits clés en main traitement des
friches facilité ou encore verdissement
de la commande publique sont des
éléments qui vont reconnaissons le dans
le bon sens maintenant si nous prenons
le temps de revenir sur le terme
industriel verte
reconnaissons qu'il y a là une forme de
mirage sémantique propice à la
communication politique
l'industrie verte n'existe pas elle est
d'ailleurs pas définie dans ce texte et
elle ne fait pas l'objet d'une stratégie
partagée au mieux en réalité il s'agit
d'un timide j'ai bien dit timide
verdissement de l'industrie s'il y avait
une volonté de construire l'industrie
verte alors nous aurions une ambition
globale
l'administration c'est plutôt traité
dans ce texte mais rien sur le
financement aussi peu alors que ce texte
nous avait été présenté comme une
réponse à l'IRA des États-Unis ou les le
gouvernement américain a accepté de
mettre sur la table 370 milliards de
dollars faut-il le rappeler on nous
parle de crédit d'impôts qui vont
facilement revenir à ceux qui sont les
Big Five et qui sont déjà en quelque
sorte vert sans qu'on y voit plus
davantage à part quelques dispositifs
que nous considérons comme inopérant
inefficace et ne touchant pas leur cible
je pense au plan épargne à venir climat
rien sur la question de l'emploi sur
l'attractivité des métiers s'il y avait
la volonté de définir et de construire
l'industrie verte de main des carbonée
alors nous prendrions du temps pour
parler de ces sujets parce que nous
savons que dans la tête de nos jeunes la
question de la perspective d'avenir se
construit sur la capacité à s'exaucer
dans une carrière professionnelle et
qu'aujourd'hui l'image de l'industrie
pêche encore en la matière malgré un
certain nombre d'initiatives au fond on
veut et en réalité strictement
réindustrialiser le pays et c'est une
bonne chose
tenter de verdir pourquoi pas mais cela
reste timide et flou puisque au fond il
n'y a rien sur la citation globale à
économiser la ressource il n'y a rien
sur l'interrogation qu'on pourrait avoir
à se poser ensemble sur les incitations
effectives à limiter les gaz à effet de
serre ou encore sur le changement du
modèle de production qui nous
permettrait de dire nous la France
au-delà
décarbonée nous avons envie d'une
industrie verte celle qui est capable de
verdir nos pratiques celles qui
permettra de considérer que nous faisons
des efforts qui vont dans le bon sens
alors ce texte nous l'accompagnerons
sans mirage sémantique sans
communication politique que vous nous
vous laisserons un fort heureusement
parce que nous savons que ce texte il
peut sur la question administrative
aller dans le bon sens mais que
malheureusement il est vite
soigneusement un certain nombre de
piliers indispensables à la réalisation
de la réindustrialisation française je
vous remercie merci monsieur le député
dernier inscrite madame Emmanuel Ménard
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues faire de la France la
championne de l'industrie verte en
Europe tel est le vœu du gouvernement
pour cela Bercy 17 retroussé les manches
pour défendre une panoplie de mesure
très technique qui quoi que pour
certaines intéressantes ne sont
malheureusement pas tout à fait à la
hauteur des ambitions affichées car nous
vous en déplaise il ne s'agit pas
seulement de rattraper le temps perdu
mais bien de se préparer aux immenses
chocs énergétiques à venir bien loin
d'une révolution verte le projet de loin
que nous le projet de loi que nous
examinons reste mythique sur les
contraintes qui déjà pointent leur nez
des contraintes que tout le monde
connaît mais dont personne n'ose parler
je pense entre autres à la production
électrique non fossiles qui aura du mal
à satisfaire une demande démultipliée
tout comme la pénurie de courant vert
qui est un risque à anticiper pour notre
industrie sans oublier naturellement la
très forte concurrence reproduit
électrique les voitures évidemment qui
pourraient nous faire perdre la bataille
face au chinois et ce ne sont pas les
injonctions du tout électrique dès 2035
sans aucune étude d'impact qui vont nous
rassurer difficile également de mettre
sous le tapis la question de
l'approvisionnement en métaux rares
nécessaires à la transition écologique
véritable nerf de la guerre mais déjà
identifié comme critique par les
spécialistes un problème qu'il serait
coupable d'ignorer car il va infiner
nous pousser vers toujours plus de
dépendance envers les pays exploitants
en minéraux comme par exemple la Chine
toujours elle loin du patriotisme
économique la transition écologique nous
pousse dès lors dans les bras de nos
concurrents quand ils ne sont pas nos
adversaires mais qu'importe puisque la
mode est au vert autant ne pas lésiner
la décarbonation de l'industrie
existante et la production de nouvelles
technologies permettant d'accélérer à la
décarbonation sont les deux nouvelles
jambes sur lesquelles nous allons devoir
apprendre à marcher nous appuyons au
passage sur les Big Five et éolienne
panneau photovoltaïques batteries
électriques électrolyseur pour fabriquer
de l'hydrogène vert et pompe à chaleur
un apprentissage périlleux car sommet
d'embûches et d'injonctions
contradictoires car si le Gouvernement
présente ce texte comme un véritable
tour nom pour notre économie pour mettre
fin à l'impardonnable travail de SAP de
notre industrie depuis plusieurs
décennies qui a quand même vu la
délocalisation de 2,5 millions d'emplois
difficile de ne pas aborder le vrai
sujet qui fâche le foncier le bien le
plus difficile à trouver pour un
industriel qui veut investir car si nous
pouvons nous accorder sur la protection
de notre environnement avec l'objectif
de zéro artificialisation net d'ici 2050
et saluer la mise à disposition par
l'état de 50 sites pour 2000 hectares
intégralement des pollués il ne reste
pas moins que la limitation de la
bétonisation risque de mettre quelques
bâtons dans les roues de notre
j'ai d'ailleurs et à plusieurs reprises
déjà évoquées la nécessité que des
entreprises comme genevia à Béziers
puissent être considérés comme étant des
projets industriels d'intérêt national
visant notamment à favoriser la
transition énergétique ou à assurer
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
et à ce titre être retiré de l'objectif
zen des collectivités c'est tout à fait
primordial pour finir je voudrais
pointer du doigt quelques contradictions
si le ministre de l'Économie Bruno Le
Maire se targue de soutenir des deux
mains l'industrie verte en instaurant
des crédits d'impôts qui seront intégrés
à la future loi de finances 2024 on ne
peut pas passer sous silence la menace
que vous avez laissé planer qu'il a
laissé planer lors des rencontres
économiques d'Aix-en-Provence au début
de ce mois que la dernière tranche de
suppression de 4 milliards d'euros
d'impôts de production promise dans le
budget 2024 pourrait bien être reportée
le en même temps à ses limites en guise
de conclusion
rappelons que si notre salut doit passer
par le verre nos besoins en électricité
seront exponentielles alors où le
nucléaire subit encore les affres de la
gauche si nous ne soutenons si nous ne
soutenons pas plus encore cette énergie
mal aimée mais propre il serait plus
étonnant que nous tenions la distance
espérons au moins que les 23 milliards
d'euros d'investissement et 40 000
emplois directs promis par le
gouvernement comme conséquence directe
de ce projet de loi ne soit pas un
énième mirage enfin je ne peux que
regretter que ce texte que vous
présentez volontiers comme une boîte à
outils ne retienne une fois encore que
les propositions de la majorité plus des
deux tiers de mes amendements ont été
déclarés irrecevables comme cavalier
pour la plupart drôle de méthode vous
l'avouerez pour un objectif qui se veut
national je vous remercie
merci Madame la député la discussion
générale est close et je donne donc la
parole à Monsieur le Ministre délégué en
charge de l'Industrie si monsieur le
Président je ne doute pas que les
députés ici présents sont extrêmement
impatients d'entamer l'examen des 1208
amendements à examiner donc je vais
faire bref mais malgré tout monsieur
Fournier
monsieur Fournier pardon vous nous
reprochez d'opposer le climat des
affaires et le climat tout court depuis
2017 nous avons montré que nous sommes
capables de réconcilier l'un et l'autre
depuis 2017 le produit intérieur brut
français il a cru de 15%. les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre française ont
baissé de 12%. et dans l'industrie 12%
également c'est 50 millions de tonnes de
CO2 en moins émis par la France on n'est
pas encore 900 millions que le député de
gainski nous a rappelé nous devons faire
dans les années qui viennent mais oui
soyons fiers du fait que la France
depuis 5 ans conformément à ce que clam
monsieur guteres a été capable de créer
de l'emploi de réindustrialiser et de
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et évidemment monsieur Fournier il
faut accélérer il faut pas freiner il
faut mettre le pied sur l'accélérateur
de manière à ce que la France oui soit
un exemple sur les voies de la
croissance verte c'est pas la croissance
à tout prix vous le savez nous portons
dans ce projet de loi un article
extrêmement important l'article 4 qui va
permettre d'avoir une industrie plus
sobre plus économe en ressources mais
oui nous devons absolument montrer que
la France est capable de produire est
capable de créer de l'emploi industriel
et je corrige une dernière fois le
chiffre monsieur Isard c'est pas 90 000
emplois c'est 100000 emplois industriels
qui ont été créés depuis six ans grâce à
cette majorité grâce à ce gouvernement
tout enjol le répète réduisant les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre on
peut le faire et on peut le faire
monsieur Loubet et monsieur Alexandre
qui une fois de plus se retrouve dans
une convergence improbable sans avoir
recours à un protectionnisme bête et
méchant ou social et écologique quand
vous fermez une porte vous la fermez
dans les deux sens si vous interdisez
les importations en France vous
interdirez aussi au champion français
d'exporter donc essayons d'être
raisonnable et intégrons évidemment dans
la commande publique ça a été dit sur
tous les bancs des critères
environnementaux qui vont nous permettre
de faire en sorte que les champions
français oui soit plus présent dans la
commande publique mais ne faisons pas de
manière aveugle ne fermez pas les portes
l'industrie française elle est capable
de conquérir le monde elle le fait dans
l'aéronautique elle le fera demain dans
l'hydrogène dans les panneaux solaires
dans l'automobile j'en suis convaincu
donnant lui les moyens de le faire
merci à Messieurs messieurs Isard
messieurs Thiébaut et monsieurzeinski
vous avez bien décrit ce projet de loi
qui est un maillon qui est un maillon
d'une chaîne que nous avons entamé il y
a maintenant 6 ans que nous allons
poursuivre de manière à développer
l'industrie française ça a été très bien
dit par les uns les autres ce projet
doit être un tout qui lui-même fait
partie d'une stratégie industrielle que
certains d'entre vous il faut le
reconnaître nous ont reproché de
présenter de manière insuffisamment
globale insuffisamment cohérente dans le
cadre de la Commission et dans le cas de
ces déclarations je tiens à vous dire
que le fameux article indice a fera
l'objet je pense d'un bon kilo
d'amendement dans quelques heures qui
nous permettra de discuter tout ça nous
sommes prêts à prendre un amendement je
pense qu'il est présenté par la députée
Bolivar qui nous permettra régulièrement
d'avoir une discussion approfondie sur
la stratégie industrielle et la
stratégie industrie verte de la France
j'espère que ça fera tomber un certain
nombre de prévention des uns des autres
et vous conduira donc à voter ce projet
de loi extrêmement important merci à la
député du bimmunère et au député bolo du
groupe de suivi que vous avez piloté
tous les deux dans le cadre des travaux
de la commission d'affaires économiques
vous avez fait un certain nombre de
recommandations nous sommes prêts à en
prendre un certain nombre vous
regrettiez par exemple l'insuffisance
association des élus locaux vous le
savez dans l'article 9 nous sommes prêts
à avancer là-dessus en donnant un avis
très tôt dans le processus au maire de
manière à ce que les projets d'intérêt
national restent évidemment ancrés dans
le local vous avez aussi fait des
propositions sur le recensement du
foncier extrêmement importante je pense
pas qu'elle soit de nature législatives
mais nous avons déjà entamé un travail
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
monsieur le seul vous avez critiqué la
méthode
reconnaissez-le vous nous vous avons
reçu avec Bruno Le Maire à l'Assemblée
au ministère des Finances comme tout
comme tous les groupes ici présents nous
vous avons écouté vous nous avez exprimé
les priorités qui étaient les vôtres
évidemment monsieur Fournier on n'est
pas d'accord sur tout donc évidemment
monsieur Fournier on va pas prendre trop
vos amendements vous avez un projet
alternatif présentez-le devant les
Français mais en attendant reconnaissez
tous et toutes qu'au Sénat et qu'en
commission spéciale nous avons pris des
amendements de tous les groupes de tous
les groupes
de tous les groupes
et nous sommes prêts à en prendre
d'autres évidemment dans le cadre des
discussions monsieur jumelles les cocos
veulent pas de leçon mais je suis pas là
pour vous donner des leçons et je suis
prêt même à reconnaître que le Parti
communiste français et eu raison avant
beaucoup d'autres sur les risques de la
des industrialisation on est où on est
maintenant et je suis persuadé que le
réveil collectif
on est capable de le porter ensemble
vers une industrie française
conquérrante et que oui vous l'avez dit
au fond j'adhère à peu près à tout ce
que vous avez dit c'est par le
verdissement de l'industrie de toute
l'industrie qu'on va réussir à illustrer
la France chez vous en Normandie et
ailleurs les Alpines si elles sont pas
électriques elles ne seront pas et vous
le savez les Alpines demain seront
électriques la capture de carbone en
Seine-Maritime si on ne la fait pas on
aura plus de production d'engrais en
Seine-Maritime on aura plus de
cimenterie on aura plus de raffinerie
donc évidemment nous sommes d'accord
avec vous il y a une chose sur lequel on
n'est pas d'accord avec vous c'est la
qualification en fait syrienne de notre
politique nous sommes aujourd'hui avec
un taux de prélèvement obligatoire
unique au monde c'est un record français
c'est un record mondial 45% personne ne
fait mieux ne nous qualifiez pas ne nous
qualifiez pas s'il vous plaît
de majorité néolibérale
qui
est contre l'impôt quoi qu'il arrive
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire au Sénat
je vous le redis aujourd'hui monsieur
jumelles moi je ne fais pas partie des
gens qui considèrent que l'impôt est un
gros mot l'impôt c'est très bien l'impôt
la peau ça permet de financer des
services publics l'impôt ça permet
d'assurer la solidité nationale la peau
ça permet de faire de la redistribution
et vous savez quoi on fait déjà tout ça
très bien en France ce que nous
considérons c'est qu'il y a des limites
à tout et qu'effectivement à 45% de la
richesse nationale je pense que la
solidarité elle est présente les
services publics on peut toujours les
améliorer ils sont présents et la
redistribution vous le savez la France
et le pays qui redistribuent le mieux
les écarts de rémunération avant et
après redistribution sont les plus
faibles au monde monsieur sa tuile merci
pour votre intervention vous avez le bon
chiffre c'est bien 11% du produit
intérieur brut aujourd'hui une industrie
pas neuf comme je l'ai entendu sur
d'autres bancs et nous devons nous
devons tout faire pour pour la croître
l'amener à 15 vous avez mentionné des
enjeux extrêmement importants et un
certain nombre d'autres l'ont fait sur
les filières les filières doivent avoir
une stratégie de décarbonation vous le
savez il y a aujourd'hui 19 comités
stratégiques de filière qui sont en
train de resigner des nouveaux contrats
qui sont tous axés sur la décarbonation
le comité stratégique de filière le
Conseil national de l'industrie créé par
Nicolas Sarkozy il y a 15 ans ça marche
nous devons mobiliser l'ensemble des
filières et pour les uns les autres je
vous le rappelle les organisations
syndicales sont présentes dans tous les
comités stratégiques de filière elles
sont présentes au Conseil de la
nationale de l'industrie donc ne nous
reprochez pas de ne pas associer des
organisations syndicales assez
stratégies elles le sont à tous les
étages
voilà je ne serai pas plus long je suis
évidemment extrêmement heureux de passer
à l'examen des amendements et je ne
doute pas que cet examen nous permettra
à tous et à toutes de nous retrouver
derrière ce beau projet de loi et une
industrie française verte et conquérante
merci